you just came back from your first
holiday
in quite a while with my first holiday
of let's say three weeks or more in
quite a while how was that uh astounding
um really uh very good to see what's
going on in the rest of the world at
this particular moment
um we had previously gone to India in
the year to visit family this was to go
back to Turkey
and to go to Portugal but also to the
Azores Islands and
um
I can't tell you how meaningful it was
for me to be back traveling why
well I mean partially it's really
equipped when you have children and
children change your game for about two
decades you have to realize that that's
a transient period it felt like it was
going to go on forever and so this was
sort of trying to figure out what is it
like to go from traveling in your 20s
and 30s without kids to traveling with
your kids at the last moment that you
still have them at home
um and now you're gonna have the rest of
your life without them again but you
can't go back to backpacking and doing
certain other things that were easy for
you so you have to figure out how to
rejoin your previous life that has been
in progress without you actually pending
for a long time a sabbatical from Life
almost the other thing is that
um you forget about parts of yourself
like I forgot that
that I spoke Turkish not well but I
spoke rudimentary Tarzan Turkish 30
years ago and to be back in Istanbul and
to suddenly have words and phrases and
things come back
um and be talking to cab drivers and and
just people in the street seeing the
change obviously there's been an
enormous amount of change in Turkey
Portugal is fascinating seeing certain
things at the end of their life cycle we
were at a synagogue in Bursa where the
sort of the home of the Ottoman Empire
where they were down to like the last 50
people which is a common enough thing uh
when we visit diaspora Jewish
communities sort of at the tail end with
the Embers still glowing hot but no no
chance for a rebirth and then in the
Azores
um
I was not prepared for the level of
beauty that we encountered
there is a level of beauty that I've
only experienced two maybe three times
in my life
that sort of leaves you physically sick
like ill
it's so beautiful that your your body is
the weak link like you might think that
sugar is tasty but if you were to eat a
bag of sugar you'd probably be sick to
your stomach and I would say this was
like so much beauty that
it was at an almost pathological level
and more than more than I think my
family could really take in we're just
so moved I've heard you say before about
how a lot of the time you don't realize
the last time you're going to do a thing
with a person yeah and a lot of friends
especially ones that are fathers have
told me the same thing the last time
that you'll bounce your daughter on your
knee you don't know when it's gonna
happen but it's going to happen there's
also a really strange realization when
you get deeper into adulthood and work
out that probably by the age of 18 or 20
you've spent 97 or 98 of the time you're
going to spend with your parents and all
that you wanted for the last four years
was to be away from them and now all
that you want is to have a little bit
more time and it's all gone and you
squandered it while it was there I'm on
the ethnic program we don't believe in
this stuff
um
my children don't become adults at the
age of 18 I don't care about the laws of
the United States or the state of
California I think we do family wrong in
the states
well you send them off to college and
then you tell them go follow your dream
and they bounce into some locality that
you aren't in and you don't get the
benefit of these very strong families
because the market has been so strong in
the US for so long the market more or
less took over all sorts of Duties that
were assigned to families historically
and so the reason that people always say
oh your families are weak was because
our markets were strong
right and so insurance and opportunity
all of these things that
um
could be
handed over to the market were and as a
result when we find out that the markets
are not safe
we we realize that we've abandoned the
structures that we needed to retreat to
that our families are quite small below
replacement rate very often and we don't
live in the same place and so you know I
married a woman from India and I
basically carry a lot of Eastern
European norms and so my feeling is that
my children are my children forever
and I'm not letting go of them and this
idea that it's your life and you can do
what you want is only true up to a point
you also have a continuity issue and
this is normal by the way and it may
sound weird in an American context
but I think that the world recognizes
that we're links in a chain and there's
a certain amount that you get to do
that's just yours because it's your life
but never go full Billy Joel
yeah pan generational housing is
something being in Austin people getting
ranches starting even com you know 10
family mini villages with a bunch of
other people yeah I it's something that
I'm seeing occur more and more and you
know in an atomized like Mass solipsism
Mass individualism Society this doesn't
sound like
we got to the end of that dream and it
it didn't it didn't work
you've been around a lot of very
powerful very rich people throughout
your career no no that's not true only
relatively only in the last decade and a
half that's quite a while in in many
people's lives what do you think that
most normal people would be surprised to
know about the powerful and the rich
individuals World Views the way that
they hold themselves what is and isn't
true they feel powerless
that's one of the craziest things is
that very often you're at a table of
people of immeasurable wealth
and they're talking about the rich
or the hyper-connected they don't see
themselves in these terms
why uh I think there's different kinds
of Rich to be to be honest I think that
if for example you got rich from arms
from let's say uh arms manufacturing
you've been entwined with government
your whole life or if agriculture
something that's highly regulated that's
uh
extraction on oil and gas those people I
think have always been close to power a
lot of the dream of tech for example was
we don't need the government
we'll just build stuff in our garages
and if it's cool it'll take care of
itself and therefore we're minimally
dependent on the traditional
ecosystems
so a lot of tech money
felt disenfranchised
they didn't know how to play the game
and that was both to its credit and uh a
huge danger but I I think one of the
things that I find very interesting is
that when people are not rate limited by
money
they're rate limited by all sorts of
other things they may they may not want
their number to to go down so they go
from 6 billion to 4 billion would be a
huge blow even though it doesn't seem to
impact normal things
um
another thing is is that most of them
have given up on the retail notion of
reality
whatever mainstream media you know if
you have a world view that allows you to
listen to National Public Radio to that
then reads the Wall Street Journal and
and the times in the New Yorker whatever
that point of view is most of the very
powerful rich people I know
have have checked out at a level
um that is astounding they don't believe
that they can afford to depend on normal
institutions how does that show up in
their lives
weird ways
um you know they don't have a regular
doctor they have concierge medicine
they're fire policy comes with a private
fire department that will fight for
their home but won't necessarily fight
for the homes next door I didn't know
that that was a thing okay
um
you know uh it's not until you travel
with some of these people that you you
realize that there's a secret Corridor
in the airport or a way of getting onto
the plane this is oh there's a lot of
infrastructure built for a very small
number of people
and
um for the most part they can't figure
out what to do with the money and it's
my belief so they
if you believe that the world is headed
towards an apocalypse
you're very unlikely to want to
contribute money because that's the only
fungible thing you have in an emergency
and so I think that a lot of the sort of
apocalyptic thinking of very powerful
people is very destructive because
they're they're trying to figure out how
to survive a mild apocalypse like a six
months of your you know if I have six
months of of canned goods and I've got
four ex-navy seals on my property
in a remote location of Montana
can I can I weather the storm with a few
diesel generators
so if it's a very mild apocalypse maybe
they've got six months plan
um but a lot of I think that there's a
lot of thinking that you should husband
your resources because you don't know
what's coming given that things are
going to have to collapse now I think
it's very sad because those are the
people who could Shore up the system
it's interesting
to think about helplessness at the top
end of the wealth distribution given
that a lot of people feel like they are
restricted by their material possessions
but it seems like
despite there being a lot of abundance
at least monetarily a the scarcity
mentality scales all the way up it
really does and particularly if you've
been deprived early in your life there's
something that happens where you're
nervous till you're dying day that
you're going to die under an overpass
right I'm not kidding
um one thing that I highly recommend
people never take me seriously is a
video game called a tower defense game
of Plants versus Zombies
and plants versus zombies ends in a
situation where you win all the things
you can inside of the game but somehow
you still have the ability to continue
to earn even though there's nothing left
to purchase
and the reason that I find this
fascinating is you get to watch your own
psychology which is now that you've
given yourself the ability to earn you
can't bring yourself to stop earning
even though earning has lost meaning
and so if you can't get to that in real
life you can at least get to that inside
of Plants versus Zombies and I highly
recommend it because you have to give
yourself some idea of
we have to cross Finish Lines as they
come if you decide okay when I get to 10
million dollars that's when I can afford
to become a philanthropist then you're
going to get there and you're going to
realize no the goals are gonna you know
the goal posts are gonna move so think
about how a waitress sees this
waitresses do philanthropy almost from
from the beginning they'll they'll over
tip somebody who gives them good service
and they can't afford it and you know
it's sort of it's a poverty trap when
you're at the very low end of the
earning Spectrum but I I think there's
something to take from that which is
to practice a little bit of philanthropy
and a little bit of kicking your shoes
up and not always deferring
um taking taking profit in some sense on
your success so make sure that all
throughout your life you're treating
yourself to some luxury even when you
can least afford it and you're
just exhibiting a little bit of goodness
even though you feel like you you
desperately need to build yourself up
because otherwise you'll always push it
out there's a Mogan hassle quote where
he says the best way to win the game is
to stop moving the goal posts
and
he's wrote this great book called the
psychology of money and it's true that
most people treat their goals their
relationship to their goals is like the
Horizon that for every step toward it
they get right it then moves one step
further away it's probably more like the
Horizon on a spring or on a rubber band
that it gets a little bit closer and
then it bunk it snaps away from you and
um
I've been around a lot of people that
have got chunks of wealth and
it's
a rare thing to see someone who doesn't
still have that scarcity mentality
despite the fact that they need to keep
the stock scarcity meant on it's not a
mistake
the problem is is that you also need an
abundance mentality and then you need to
selectively access them in different
circumstances talk to me about the
tension between those two well it's just
this regulated expression idea that we
keep trying to find settings where we
don't you know like just let me set the
air conditioner at 68 and then I'll be
happy forever
in reality more or less you need
contradictory facilities and you need to
know when to pull one in and let the
other out and you know this is the hard
thing anybody with multiple children
knows that you know with one kid you're
saying you cannot afford to take these
risks if you jump off something like
that you don't look below think what you
could do the other kid needs this love
nothing ventured nothing gained come on
yeah I've heard uh I've heard your
brother say uh that him and his wife's
advice to the children was as long as
you don't do anything to your eyes you
can kind of take the risks that you want
yes and no I mean there's teeth there's
throws anything somebody who does Combat
Sports is going to try and regularly
right right small joints whatever it is
there are plenty of ways to get yourself
into real trouble yep the key thing that
you're trying to use childhoods for is
to go through the mistakes that are
not permanently disfiguring it's one of
the importances of having fathers around
the importance of rough and tumble play
right is facilitated almost exclusively
yeah and you learn the limits of your
strength you learn the limits of your
body you learn how high of a tree you
can jump off and how high of a tree you
can't jump off you also learn to lose
I mean I really hate some of this winter
talk where basically people have no plan
to lose and then when they actually
experience loss they tend to throw
everything away to say I didn't lose you
know that's very interesting in other
Muse this episode is brought to you by
Shopify Shopify is the e-commerce
platform revolutionizing millions of
businesses worldwide whether you're a
garage entrepreneur or IPO ready Shopify
is the only tool you need to start run
and grow your business without any
expertise Shopify puts you in control of
every sales channel so whether you're
selling satin sheets from shopify's
in-person POS or offering organic olive
oil on shopify's e-commerce platform
they have got everything covered for you
Shopify Powers 10 of all e-commerce
across the United States massive Brands
like gymshark still use Shopify that's
how powerful it is so if you want to
start selling something anything online
Shopify is where to start you can begin
a 1 dollar per month trial period right
now by going to the link in the show
notes below or heading to shopify.com
Modern wisdom that's shopify.com
modernwisdom to take your business to
the next level today you met Jeffrey
Epstein once yep
talk to me about what that's like coming
face to face with somebody
of that caliber
whatever that means um
well
one thing is there is a physiological
reaction that corresponds to this phrase
that you know the hair on the back of my
neck stood on end
like that's a real physiological feeling
I don't know whether the hair actually
does that but it's exactly what it feels
like
you're meeting somebody who is Unholy
and
you know one of the most interesting
things is that he was beckoning into a
world that didn't seem to exist but for
him as as the door
is the doormat
I think that's one of the things that
freaked out a lot of these rich people
is is that he
he felt rich in a movie Sense which is
not something that you find among
actually rich people
what do you mean
well
a lot of very wealthy people don't own
an island
islands are really tough to to maintain
I'm obsessed with islands and you know
in general I have to be obsessed with
islands that have airports run by other
people because you know they have
populations on them
but every rich person starts to Wonder
Could I afford it can I afford an island
or how many jets if you look at Jeffrey
Epstein's wealth it was beaten it was
like gold beaten into gold foil so that
it could cover a vast area and leave the
impression of a solid gold life
but it was really probably a mid nine
figure fortune that had been used to buy
islands and plays which is not what any
nine figure person is going to
do so you had a
felt sense and embodied sense of
discomfort
oh hell yeah
and where did that come from
uh
the fact that he had a lipstick camera
pointed at me from an art object that he
laid a table that was preposterously
long and thin with a tablecloth made of
an American flag to make it look like a
coffin so that I would spill my coffee
on the flag of my own country I mean the
fact that he looked like a mutant Ralph
Lauren with this kind of lubricious
quality and he's talking all of the
science and Market stuff and nothing
adds up and there's an heiress bouncing
on his knee to get her boobs to jiggle
to see whether it can distract I mean
it's like one of these crazy scenes were
nothing about it was normal there was
just no there was no trace of a normal
world
that sounds like a script from a movie
yeah I mean I think part of it uh John
Travolta is like putting a gun to your
head and forcing you to drink and break
a code in a minute yeah like that part
of it and then there was some sort of
like you know
remember that that story The Most
Dangerous Game where a man invites you
to his Island so he can hunt you
you know this was
scary and it was it was meant to be
scary sounds menacing
well I think his product was silence
people think that his product was sex
or Finance but it was silence I'm pretty
sure how do you what something if you're
scary enough look rich people can get
sex but they can't necessarily get
people to shut up afterwards
so I my take on it and my take on it
instantly was this is not an actual
human
this is a construct of someone's someone
has created a fake human being called
Jeffrey Epstein
who's a mysterious currency trading
Finance here with Crazy rules so that no
one would ever invest with him
and I think that was to keep people from
seeking his Investment Services
I mean he you know he's labeled
disgraced financier but nobody has a
record of trading with him he was
sitting there he comes into the meeting
and he says you know well Eric I was
just doing some currency Trading
and I
I thought about that scene that you
sometimes see and as a meme with Steve
Buscemi with a skateboard over his
shoulder hello fellow Cantina just yeah
hello fellow financial traders exactly
so I'm thinking you don't really look
like a rich guy who trades in markets
the thing that's interesting that I'm
finding myself intrigued by here is
it takes a moderate amount of cognitive
horsepower
to be able to piece together this
theater that you sat down at yeah
deployed in a
nefarious malicious manipulative way
but it's smart
what do you mean it's smart it's it's
not something that could be done by a
simple mind
you think he did it
oh he has a team of manipulators
no when I say I think he was a constrict
I literally mean that I think he was
constructed
like fitted with a story
oh so you think he was a plant
no I think it was a construct what's
that like okay you're gonna have to dig
in I think
Jeffrey Epstein
Super Genius financier
was not a thing that existed
where did the money come from
I'm gonna Mumble Lex West Lexington okay
so that's what Drew mumbled but then you
know there's this missing Fortune of
Robert Maxwell and this Fortune of
Jeffrey Epstein that we don't can't
explain are those the same fortune now
it's like a conservation of uh of money
principle that if you have a fortune
that's missing and you have a fortune
that can't be explained in there
connected by gillane Maxwell I don't
know
why is it that no hedge funds what is it
they file form I forget it's 13f there's
certain forms that you have to file
um nobody's ever asked for these things
where who's this Prime broker has
somebody gone over the prime brokerage
uh his what are his trades
he would have to move the market if he
was you know doing a yard of Euros or
Swiss Francs or who knows what as like a
billion
um that would move the market so there's
no way you can fake retroactively a
hedge fund
of immeasurable size that trades
currencies I I don't think he was a
currency Trader
he told me it was a currency Trader So
when you say a construct who constructs
who's the Builder
I don't know I would imagine some
version of the intelligence community
you know sometimes somebody's cover gets
blown
um we have we have a very famous
unfortunate story of Ellie Cohn with the
Mossad where Ellie Cohn was an Egyptian
Jew who was fitted with a backstory that
he was an Argentinian Playboy
who'd made a fortune in Argentina but
was Arabic in origin and then he moves
to Damascus and he takes out an
apartment where he holds orgies
and
um becomes the best friend of hafez
al-assad right and so
that's an example of a story we know we
know how the intelligence communities of
the world create people who don't really
exist
construction of I know that this is just
a one uh time thing here that you got to
see but the construction of the coffin
looking
American flag the spelling of the coffee
this weird power play thing that's going
on
that seems now that you say that uh it
wasn't him even pulling his own strings
perhaps
it makes a lot more sense but even that
that degree of sophistication I learned
this from Daniel schmachtenberger we sat
down and he's spent some time with
particularly powerful people yeah and he
told me this really harrowing story of
somebody who has both the desire and the
means to treat themselves like an apex
predator
against that own kind and they said so
they broke the fourth wall about this
and said apex predators don't care about
the prey but they saw their own kind as
prey and I asked Daniel how does it feel
to sit opposite somebody who isn't rate
limited by the resources who can not
only dream to have this
plus uh have the motivation or lack of
virtue or Integrity to go ahead and
consider doing it and then has the
capacity the assets to be able to enact
it sure and it's reminding me it's
giving me this same
something it feels like it feels like
it's up on the top of my head it's
giving me some sort of a sense like that
this was intended to be terrifying it
wasn't an accident
it was intended to be as fascinating as
it could possibly be which it was
and terrifying at the same time and it
achieved both it achieved both
objectives
I mean I was given an opportunity to
meet him again
I didn't know what to do
I mean the other thing that I just found
really weird is that he knew about my
research and it turned out that he was
connected to my graduate department at
Harvard
so he had a connection to the Harvard
math department unbeknownst to me
I don't know when that began
I know two of the professors he was
connected through
but this is some Unholy story it has
nothing to do with Jeffrey Epstein
it has to do with whatever this thing
was we tripped over a thing
we tripped over a structure
we named the structure Jeffrey Epstein
it must be
very unfortunate in some regards for
whoever it was if that's true that was
in charge of
this Construction
that it became that people got t-shirts
with his name printed on them
this was already going wrong
in the early 2000s
you see my sense of this is that this
was a pre-internet
plan that lived into the internet age
and couldn't survive contact with the
internet age
what did the internet bring in that
didn't allow it to survive eyeballs
discussion level of surveillance well
you know there's a claim that nobody
cares about Jeffrey Epstein because it's
this many years later and we've all
moved on
yeah
that's completely untrue and we know
that it's true because if you start
talking about Jeffrey Epstein the the
engagement goes up
so you have these fictions like you know
that are
put out by mainstream Media or
traditional news desks which is nobody
cares about that story well that you can
see from social media that that's not
true from the internet so the internet
is constantly providing
an ability to check whether or not these
claims from inside the structure true
and Jeffrey Epstein is an example of
what I've called an an anti-interesting
phenomena
what's that when anti-interesting thing
is something that would normally be
fascinating imagine for example you had
a story where you could get a Pulitzer
Prize for breaking it everybody cares
you'd sell papers like hotcakes blah
blah blah and nobody wants to report on
it
and it's like right there you could just
ask the dumbest questions and it would
like
New York Times says disgraced financier
well tell me did you find his prime
broker did you find the form did you go
to his offices in vallart house no
nobody does ever
the story is anti-interesting and it's
very different than being uninteresting
which would suggest mole collusion mole
coordination
hello
I mean
see this is what this is one of the most
uncomfortable things
I think there was a time when mostly
when people said collusion or
coordination
the presumption was well that's kind of
that's pretty far out there we now know
like post Elon musk's 44 billion dollar
Adventure at Twitter
that there are these coordinating groups
coordinates coordinating social media
with the intelligence Community or with
the Department of Homeland Security or
with the state department
we now know that we're living in an
orchestrated Court you know curated
choreographed world
and we can't
know it officially but we all know it if
we want to know
which is hysterical now we have to talk
about well are you a conspiracy theorist
like
I I read
I read the slack messages I read the
emails what what are you even talking
about now
some bankman freed yeah currently being
recharged yeah with witness tampering as
well
that to me fresh charges uh releasing
even though it was totally couldn't get
in touch with the Press I think hundreds
of phone calls to the Press leaked his
ex-girlfriend allegedly
leaked his ex-girlfriend's uh diary
entries right so on and so forth and you
know this is a guy that some of my
friends were flown to go and see on his
Island yes his portion of an island yeah
his portion is very different yeah okay
uh for very different reasons as well
um
there seems to be and you you hear about
the if they believe they're Above the
Law there was this really cool
documentary on Netflix called the murder
murders and it was this small town big
family lots of money and the kids run
rampant right classic like silver spoon
aristocracy
but when it gets scaled up this much
more sambangman freed
the biggest Financial crime alleged
Financial crime
since
uh Bernie Madoff okay yeah
allegedly tampering with Witnesses
allegedly leaking his ex-girlfriend's
diary entries and
do the rules not apply to everybody
certainly they don't
why
uh we stopped Prosecuting all sorts of
types of people
you know look we stopped holding
hearings I grew up in a world where we
had the church committee the pike
committee looking at our own
intelligence Services we had Watergate
hearings we had uh tobacco hearings we
had Iran Contra hearings
do you know how many hearings we need
right now where are these things it's
ridiculous we've got weird stuff about
UFOs with people making the craziest
allegations
look
this is just not normal
we're in totally weird Uncharted
Territory
what do you make of the recent uaps I
think is the new term Eric you need to
get
up with the times here they're not UFOs
anymore that's the old I wasn't even in
this game when it was UFOs okay okay so
what do you make of the recent UAP
stories and attention and response and
subsequent response
um
I'd like to ask you first
so I had a look at the uh first
whistleblower from about two months ago
quite closely with Andy Stumpf who used
to have pretty high level security
clearance and he explained to me about
how unimpressive that particular type of
security clearance is how very common
which one this is David yes David
[Music]
no not not David fravor no no David
fravor was the Tic Tac correct this is
uh Dave garoosh yes okay
um very common level of security
clearance uh that you're using that as
some sort of uh oh this is a legitimate
credential it doesn't really wash too
much that it was
second or it was third hand information
mostly second-hand information kind of I
heard from a person who saw or who heard
right
um it just seemed to me to be
rather on the face of it
unimpressive that release I see
what did you think
well like I've been telling everybody
um
these are highly conserved stories
this is
not the only person I've heard this
story from I've heard this from multiple
people they're they're various versions
of
this Secret World which play out as
Space Opera
you know that then mj12 became the real
government that only even the president
could couldn't understand you know it's
like okay
so
that's the weird part about it until you
start realizing how sober many of the
people are who believe this and who
claim to have had Direct contact with it
and then you don't know what to do
I mean in other words
whatever this is
there is a thing
it's not necessarily little green man it
could be for example that they mock up a
floating spaceship in a hangar and then
they uh
drag people past it and say whatever you
do do not look to your left or right or
you'll be shot and then of course people
look and then like mission accomplished
now people will say oh my God you have
no idea what we the US has incredible
technology
and then maybe the idea is you've got a
cover story maybe you've got the your
adversary investing in things that don't
make any sense I don't know
but there's not nothing here this is not
about mylar balloons and seagulls
anymore
I'm trying to come up with the word for
it but it's like a
it's like recursive false Flags yeah in
a way where the goal is not to give or
hide truth the goal to fire holes with
information so much that the truth can
no longer be discerned it's a haystack
of
to make sure that any needle is very
difficult to find
it is yes hey stacking right
yeah okay so they Haystack the crap out
of this thing I have no question that
there was something that was used to
develop U.S aircraft like the B2 bomber
and the SR-71 Blackbird so if you see
something crazy in the sky better that
you think it's a UFO from outer space
than some Advanced thing from Lockheed I
have no question that we use this to
deal with things like the Chinese
balloon shoot down where we shot down
several things in a week and we couldn't
recover debris from any of them I mean
come on guys
um you know maybe the idea is that this
is a a head fake to our adversaries to
develop the wrong things and to use
their treasure on things that won't work
maybe there's a secret program uh where
some of this stuff is actually real and
true and we're not allowed to know it
because it would be too mind-blowing
maybe there's a cult uh inside of our
government that has replaced angels with
saucer-shaped aircraft
um
whatever this thing is
it's being used for many different
purposes there's something here
we just don't know what you know this is
the problem the princess can't feel a p
because that would be impossible the
princess feels a disturbance
you can't say what the disturbance is
maybe it's a golf ball
maybe it's a cantaloupe maybe it's a
banana
but whatever it is there's something
wrong with the mattress
yeah it seems to me this firehousing
the goal of uncertainty hmm right
how do things muddle out who wins in a
model is a great question we're not
taught to ask sorry to jump in on it
yeah
always look for who is trying to muddle
to win
like very often you're in a
dispute with entrenched status quo and
somebody will say well I guess we'll
have to agree to disagree on this one
like oh well who wins if we agreed it is
oh it's you
you're right yeah this is like an old
principle of mine which is that you can
always tell who's Guilty by who first
declares a time of healing
why why is that a razor to use oh
because if you do something wrong and
the public is clamoring for for for your
blood you say there's been too much uh
blame and finger pointing on all sides
at me
I think what we need is to come together
and declare a time of healing for me
right
so I believe that in general whoever
declares a time of healing is suspect
number one
that's a very nice uh razor to use
I wonder about this
oh how would you say
epidemic of uncertainty
brilliant
speaking my language
and I wonder
how first off how is an individual you
are
supposed to put up any kind of effective
defense
to just take some sovereignty being you
know an agentic individual right
and secondly I wonder what the end goal
is I I understand why uncertainty would
be useful for manipulation because if
people can't discern truth from untruth
it can be easy to poke them and prod
them and Float them in particular
directions
but it also seems like I know kind of
also useless as well that some people
um non-insignificant large cohort of
people will just reject it entirely
which actually they're doing which
actually makes it more chaotic and more
unruly so it makes me think well maybe
if this is the case if the fire hosing
is happening right it's epidemic of
uncertainty
maybe the outcomes were predicted but
haven't manifest in the way that was
intended
maybe there's more of a rebellious
streak say more about that I'm not
trying to understand that if people who
if you make the public very uncertain
about most things by overloading them
with information or by even the it
doesn't even need to be coordination it
could be a byproduct of having
24 7 access to the entire world's
population through Twitter and Instagram
stories and blah blah blah right there
is so much I can no longer discern even
due to a multiplicity of opinions that's
not coordinated to be a multiplicity
that go in opposite directions
if it was coordinated the outcomes that
are occurring at the moment a lot of the
time don't seem to be happening with
people just oh roll over tell me exactly
what to do there is a massive
non-insignificant cohort of people that
say I'm checking out and I now no longer
trust anybody at all and that doesn't
say anything yes and that doesn't seem
to be if the goal was ease of control
that doesn't seem to be effective for
the person that wanted that or the group
that wanted that to be the outcome
first of all
I'm really glad to get a question about
this as a sea change which is that
our lives have become wall-to-wall
uncertainty we can't discern if the
Japanese attacked Pearl Harbor today
we would spend 10 years discussing
whether it was a false flag whether it
was actually the Japanese whether there
was any attack whether it was a sound
stage where there was a psyop whether it
was a you know
right now
the main institutions of our society
have abdicated their role
for public spirited adjudication
of what is true based on expertise
and so what you're seeing is people
coming to hate experts in coming to hate
institutions because they're realizing
that these institutions lie to them at a
level that they've never considered
unless they were Alex Jones fans to
begin with
and so you're what you're having is
you're having a large number of people
waking up to the idea that
yeah there really are
organizations and working groups that
determine what you hear from a
multiplicity of venues it's the same
message relentlessly do you think people
are overly pattern matching that now say
more boy what you mean the the scene
conspiracy where there isn't because the
lack of faith in institutions same
person is saying that they see a
conspiracy and they see no conspiracy
they have part of their head that
remembers that conspiracy theorists are
crazy people and they've got part of
their brain that remembers that normies
who don't believe in conspiracies are
crazy people and they can't integrate
those things
right they cannot figure out how are
these things being coordinated am I a
crazy person for seeing these patterns
am I a crazy person for ignoring them
for when they're when they're Unearthed
um what you're seeing is a complete
destruction
of Bedrock reality that if you weren't
actually physically there
how do we know that these people
actually met in a warehouse is this
really a table or is it just you know
CGI was it green and we could
superimpose wood onto it nobody knows
what's true
and
you know if you if you ask me well Eric
how are you dealing with this I would
say I'm failing
I'm just flat out failing
as are all of you I'm just more honest
about it some of you have an idea that
you've got one lens
which is fix the money fix the world
Bitcoin that's the answer yeah Bitcoin
rock on but
no that's not the answer or somebody
else says you know
I really think that we just need to be
open and tolerant and realize it's a big
world and we just have to give people
their due well that doesn't work either
you can't just let
everything run Riot or we have to go
back to our institutions with these
people at the helm are you kidding we
have to abandon our institution wait
what are you saying we're going to
abandon our institutions all right do
you know what that looks like
nobody has an answer we'll get back to
talking to Eric in one minute but first
I need to tell you about gymshark
gymshark make the best training kit on
the planet this t-shirt that I've been
falling in love with and traveling in
for a very long time is phenomenal and
these shorts the studio shorts that they
make are
the best men's training shots on the
planet they have lasted me over a year
now they come in amazing colors the
length is perfect they're sweat wicking
they're lightweight they wash and dry
perfectly you don't need that many pairs
of shorts as a guy but the ones that you
do have need to be very good so if you
need new gym kit this is where to go I
highly highly recommend that you go and
check out everything that I use and
recommend from gymshark they've updated
my product page with everything that I
use and recommend for men and women and
you can get 10 off everything site-wide
with no minimum order and they have 30
day free returns worldwide head to
bit.ly shark wisdom that's bit.ly shock
wisdom and use the code mw10 a checkout
you're sounding an awful lot parallel
the conversation is moving in a similar
direction to one I had with Sam Harris
recently I would think it's very
different but happy to hear more
he identified on an episode that I did
with him not long ago
the fact that we have lost trust in our
institutions and yet abandoning them is
also wholesale is is also not an option
Sam also tried
to say I can see the problems on the ICM
can see the problems on the right and I
can see the problems on the left and
there is a group of people
who have allowed their irritation with
the left
to color their thinking to the point
that they now are in a right-wing
situation without understanding the
dangers on the right
I think Sam is discounting the idea that
once people wake up to the I to the
concept that they were living in an
orchestrated Truman Show
that they did not understand
they're not going to have the idea of
like oh sure the vaccines were a little
bit more dangerous than claimed and
maybe a little bit less effective and
maybe we knew a little bit more about
the loudly no way
you spat directly in my face and told me
not only that it was raining but that I
was a crazy person for thinking that you
spat directly in my face and you piled
up how many Nobel laureates to defend
uh the idea that any inquiry into the
origin of this virus was racism
it's like you're dead to me
and I think that that's what people are
not understanding in the Democratic
party on
increasingly the basic attitude is
whoever this class of people is that
crawled into our Elite institutions is
just dead
like there's nothing Anthony fauci could
say at this moment that I want to hear
it's not that I don't think that he
doesn't know virology or epidemiology
I know I can't trust him because of the
way in which he looked into my eyes
and then you know when Stephen Colbert
is Dancing with syringes singing the
vaccine song
and Ariana Grande you know is in a super
highly produced number from like
Hairspray but converted to vaccines
uh with a giant picture of Anthony fauci
and everybody's celebrating like it's a
May Day celebration
um I get it I live in a completely fake
world and I wrote an article about this
in 2011 on kfabe which is the system of
lies that undergirds professional
wrestling so now you're you've woken up
to the idea that you've spent your life
watching something like major league
baseball or Premier League soccer
whatever it is
and it's all fake
and now you don't know who you are you
don't know who your country is you don't
know what a Ballot Box is you have no
idea what news is or media you don't
know what a university is actually
teaching
you've got people running around who are
calling themselves Scholars who publish
in scholarly journals and sit in
scholarly seats and you can tell what
they're saying is completely wrong and
it's directly in their area of expertise
so the thing about patent matching that
I said was
there are still many people who are
Scholars who are in positions of
authority inside of highfaluting
institutions
the presumably do want to do good and do
want to deploy their skills in a way
that does this
is it a case that every single
institution is completely wrong or
is this reflexive
skepticism yeah
being tuned up too highly to the point
where there is skepticism about things
that don't deserve it and how do we
determine between the two okay so we
have to talk about the institutions that
are fighting back Twitter which has
become X is not on the same standard
that the uh Facebooks are or Google is
Elon is doing something different we can
talk about what
the University of Chicago is still
fighting
uh my daughter just graduated from the
University of Chicago I never mentioned
where she was while she was there
um
it is it needs it needs support
we have to support the schools that
fought back for example I believe Ohio
State fought back and there's a school
in Oklahoma that fought back
and leading that charge is the
University of Chicago we have
organizations like fire
uh that promote Free Speech uh we have
professors who are taking on some risk
like Jonathan height but we're not
seeing the gnome Chomsky effect where
you do amazing research and they have to
put up with every crazy idea that comes
through your mind
right
that's important
look up a person named Serge Lang in
mathematics and something called the
file to understand how dangerous it is
to screw with real Scholars what happens
give us the 30 000 foot View
you know they put people tried to put
like say Sam Huntington into the
National Academy of Sciences who was an
architect of the Vietnam War and sirs
Lang just said I looked through his
papers I find the following mathematical
statements this is not science why is
this person in the academy and then they
fight back
and I fought back with Sarah slang when
he was at Harvard
where we tried to engage Sam Huntington
on on that topic you can't have these
dangerous people running around that's
why all of us are discredited maybe you
haven't noticed this
but like Jordan Peterson is discredited
Sam Harris as discredited Joe Rogan is
discredited Brett Weinstein as
discredited Ben Shapiro is discredited
Barry Weiss is discredited everybody
is discredited Tim Paul referred to it
as the idw's Walking Corpse phase at the
moment well
my point is this personal destruction is
the coin of the realm and some of the
personal destruction that you see that
looks organic is is orchestrated as well
and we're just in this thing where in my
opinion what you're looking at is
something called deconfliction but
people don't know what that is
deconfliction is supposed to stop what
are called Blue on Blue incidences so
Blue on Blue incidences you have two
branches of government that don't know
that they're operating covertly so maybe
you have an investigative team and an
undercover team and the investigative
team is about to blow the cover thinking
that they've got a Target but it's
actually an undercover agent
so what they're supposed to do is
they're supposed to check in with these
centralized systems and say do you have
any assets in this Arena we're about to
move yes we do oh okay so
they find out and this is supposed to
stop Blue on Blue
the interesting thing is even though
there are three systems called safetynet
RIS safe and case Explorer you can't use
them unless you are an official part of
the government
so I called up one of them had a half an
hour conversation before I started
asking about Jeffrey Epstein and then
they immediately said this call will be
terminated in five seconds
uh for maybe it was cases case Explorer
for South Florida something like that
what happens when you have a civilian
that's not signed up
for non-disclosure under no rules you're
an American citizen with full right to
free speech and you stumble on something
that you're not supposed to know about
that is a deconfliction problem that
nobody has ever solved so the first
thing I'd like to throw at is if we have
three separate systems to keep like the
intelligence community and local police
departments from tripping over each
other
what do you think we do
when ordinary citizens get wind of
something amiss that some super secret
operation
and my claim is we discredit them
we pre-bunk them in the language of the
gec I believe
you see
we're all familiar we're all familiar
with debunking
misinformation and disinformation you've
got some disinformation that's spread it
around we debunk it by giving you the
truth what happens when somebody is
spreading the truth in a way that is
unhelpful
to a statecraft level narrative
well we didn't know what the words were
but we just found out and it's you
pre-bunk the Mal information
now if you didn't grow up knowing what
Mal information is here's a
quick refresher Mal information is
actual information
but it's harmful
right the equivalent of Politically
Incorrect Incarnation well or you know
you're trying to make sure that uh
there's support for the war in Ukraine
and somebody actually realizes that
things are much more desperate than than
they thought well that would be
deleterious to our our efforts if the
objective is to get potent to capitulate
so now you have to pre-bunk
the Mal information which means destroy
the reputation
of the person spreading the information
that's countering the official
disinformation and misinformation
so I can't work out why anybody's
confused and why they're having trouble
existing in the stay in school kids
um
the point is I've got all of these
friends who are pre-bunked malinformers
that's what a club what a club that's
what I do
I'm a pre-bunked malinformant
there's never been a sexier title I
spread malinformation yeah and I need to
be pre-bunked so of course I'm going to
be a grifter
I'm going to be I don't know Charlotte
and I'm gonna well he's over
can we stop trying to make Eric
Weinstein a thing blah blah blah and
there's a you know giant Farms of of
people and Bots that are dedicated to
spreading bad feelings about anybody
who's gonna contradict narrative well
don't forget as well that
the coordination doesn't necessarily
need to be there because the incentives
align online
there's an emergent part there's a
non-emergent part correct I will not
agree with anyone who tells me it's all
one or the or all the other but part of
this is actually coordinated yeah
so close that loop on the
agentic sovereign individual existing in
the world
holy I'm getting bukakied with this
total awfulness of of information here
lukaki just means splattered in Japanese
that's why it's not a terrible term to
use absolutely thank you it's actually
been appropriated by the adult industry
in a way that I think the Japanese
should reclaim actually Melissa Chen has
probably done more to popularize this in
intellectual circles than anyone else so
shout out to Miss Melissa Chad Melissa
Chen and bukaki in the same sentence
something that we weren't expecting
today she uh I think there was a period
of her life where she would use it in
every public appearance just sneak it in
right okay the of the gaps
so anyway you have a situation where
nobody knows what's going on and I don't
think Sam is comfortable by the way
being here like you're in Open Water
and you have all of these instructions
about what to do when you're swimming
near land which is you know try to align
yourself with the shore don't fight the
current and like that's not where you
are you're just in Open Water
and you're treading water and you don't
know whether they're oceanic white tips
around and you don't know whether you
can keep this up for much longer
but there is no land
there's a big difference with Sam
go a little deeper make that a little
plainer for me
you cannot trust Harvard
or nature
you cannot trust the Office of
Management and budget all the Lancet or
the Lancet or the Bureau of Labor
Statistics
you cannot trust
any newspaper that I'm aware of you
cannot trust the CDC or the NIH
or The Who
now
people will hear that and they'll say oh
my God Eric you're spreading distrust
and fear it's like I'm a pastor shoot
the messenger all you want
all of those institutions are out of
control and we all know it
and entirely out of control no mostly I
did this on trigonometry we have this
anti-institutional point how is it that
the airlines can't keep my seat clean
uh and can't make sure that I'm able to
recline it properly or that the Wi-Fi
doesn't go out and then their planes
never crash
so the institutions are functioning and
not functioning they're lying and
telling the truth they're getting it
done and failing outright over and over
again
and it's it's even worse because if if
the planes crashed all the time then
you'd say okay well these people are
incompetent
but it's like the selective
incompetence and Madness and
what I think is is that Sam wanted to
treat this as look it's pretty annoying
what's going on on the left and it's
pretty annoying what's going on with the
institutions but let's not let's not
lose sight of the fact
January 6th
people don't feel that way people feel
like wait a minute I don't know which
end is up I don't know who's telling me
the truth anymore I can spot these lies
that are so transparent and this is the
theory of Lies as a checksum
so when you get a binary for a computer
program that you want to install on your
computer you want to know well is this
what came from Microsoft or did somebody
adulterate it and when I click on this
thing it's going to install ransomware
on on my machine so there's something
called a checksum
which is generated by how the program
was compiled
and it would be almost impossible to
come up with a second program that would
generate the same checksum verification
yeah
if the check sum is off I don't install
the thing and the checksums are all off
and that's why people are going crazy
and that's why to your earlier point
isn't it interesting that we're not
talking about the level of uncertainty
right like this is not sustainable so
Sam is 100 correct on a lot of things
that people are making fun of him for
and I assume that I will be uh Keel
hauled all over Twitter for saying this
you cannot have a world without
institutions we're not built for it
we're just there's no part of you that
is prepared to generate all your own
electricity and and you know kill all
your own game and
get your own clean water and
it's
you need an army
you need a police department you can
only play
um Frontier you know Wild West so long
before you realize that Modern Life
can't be supported this
and we can't go with the institutions we
have
so we need institutions we can't go with
these institutions not because the
institutions are wrong but because the
inhabitants are wrong to a person
they've been selected for by this
ability to lie because growth evaporated
that's one of my main riffs we don't
have to go into it but it basically that
in the absence of real growth everything
turns pathological
and so it's just heartbreaking to see
some of these people saying look we've
always known that the institutions were
wrong we finally have the ability to
prove that let's tear them all down so
that's a very popular perspective at the
moment other people want to claim let's
cling to the institutions because we
know we need them and we'll look past
the fact that they're obviously lying
about almost everything of importance
that's not really tenable we can't vote
these people out because like Dianne
Feinstein could beat me easily in a run
uh you know for for Senate I don't know
why because the machine
is stronger than actually the the vision
we had for democracy so we've got you
know Mitch McConnell having a
temporary you know ischemic attack on
camera we've got somebody post-stroke in
Pennsylvania
uh having defeated Mehmet Oz we've got
Dianne Feinstein we've got
um Nancy Pelosi trading up a storm we
can't get rid of any of these people Joe
Biden is way too old for this job and
has been in government since he was 29
in 1972 when he won his senate seat
this is a joke it's beyond Preposterous
and by the way it comes out of not
loving your children
also
people who love their children don't
drill holes in their children's life
raft
in the Modern World post-world War II
was a life raft to get us to the next
stage and the number of
older people I see liquidating
everything
so that they can live out their final
days in the same style to which they've
become accustomed is impossible in a
world where people love their children
it's Cavalier with the future
yeah I don't think they care
are you familiar with Toby ord's analogy
of the precipice no tell me really cool
so his book The precipice that everybody
should go and read it's my best primer
on existential risk Toby odds from the
future of humanity Institute at Oxford
with Nick Bostrom and he's a colleague
of William mccaskill long-termism EA Etc
and um he uses this example of you can
imagine on a journey yeah a particular
individual getting to a beautiful Lush
abundant Meadow would have to take a
treacherous mountain path and along this
mountain path there is a particularly
thin small steep sharp uncertain
unstable part of it that's the precipice
and he talks about you could I I like to
think about it like an hourglass okay
you have width with room and then you
have a choke point and that that choke
point things can get dicey and it's
Toby's contention that if we make it
through this precipice you broaden out
and you have the meadow uh you are a
multi-planetary species you have
redundancy genetically redundancy these
civilizationally uh you have overcome
some of the limitations of the cast Ops
from your energy production and
consumption
you don't have value lock in in a bad
way that means that it's despots all the
way down or it's tyrants assume that I
hear you yep
where do you think we are
it feels very precipice yeah doesn't it
yeah
what's more
as one of the only people who are really
seriously hitting this multi-planetary
note
there is no interest in this
from who
I'm interested are you yeah don't I
count Eric am I not legitimate in the
future of this civilization's direction
what what
what are your best stories for how we
become interplanetary I say it because
you brought it up stories or strategies
stories about how we get to be
interplanetary I'm not sure what you
mean by story
tell me a story
by which we have ten planets
the human humans have settled
well if you want to do 10 we're going to
have to go to planets that are outside
of the solar system right so that
there's this one which is really
troubling
Mars is really screwing up this whole
story because Elon has gotten everybody
fix I focus on Mars and it's the only
it's a marginal planet
it would be very difficult to get to
using chemical rockets and it's not a
stepping stone because once you master
Mars if if if if which we're not going
to do
it doesn't really get you anywhere
it's just Mars
so Avi lobe yep new book that recently
came out Interstellar spoke to him last
week about it okay I asked him about
this I said
um do will we ever visit other galaxies
and he made this cop-out answer of
saying well Andromeda is going to crash
into the Milky Way I was like that
doesn't count RV we can't blend two
together and say that we've been there
right
um and he's talking about uh
Interstellar travel right from here to
Proxima Centauri pick your other Star
right
they are trying at some point in the not
too distant future to do the light sail
laser pointed added thing maybe we can
and this was me asking him uh my
conception was generation ships you know
you and the next 500 generations of your
progeny you condemn them to be locked in
this tin box and it's
group sex and and plants and CO2 for the
next however long until you get to
Proxima Centauri hope that it's not
totally wrecked his point was light sail
uh desktop DNA sequencer artificial womb
send it out being ridiculous
it's it's a I thought this is my story I
know this is my story okay this is my
story and I'm allowed to tell my story
but it's exactly why I wanted it in fact
it just okay
it's an innervating story
what's up
we're not energized by this story
except for the group sex and the plants
right yep so the issue is if we could
sprinkle some bukaki in there everybody
would get on board a Melissa moving at
light speed
um
what we're doing is that we're telling
people we've crawled inside our modern
theories
and our modern theories make our
imaginations our enemy
we're not excited about the I we don't
really believe that we're going to open
a wormhole
we don't really believe in
multi-generation ships we don't believe
that we're going to reboot from
tardigrades we don't believe that we're
going to scan all of our synapses and
reconstruct the brain uh from the
beginning
Einstein is the problem
now I know Avi decently well and Avi
for the Galileo project that he's
heading up doesn't want people
to consider new physics so whenever I
speak at all as somebody affiliated with
the Galileo project
with wearing that hat I don't think
about new physics at all I accept the
constraints of the physics we know yes
yes yes
when I take that hat off
it's all about new physics it's not
about new technology using the old
physics
and the way you can measure whether
people are serious about interplanetary
is how much they're focused on new
physics anybody who isn't focused on new
physics is not serious about
interplanetary is this because with the
current conception of physics that we
have it's going to be essentially
impossible for us to go into planetary
yeah and the word essentially is doing
some work there and so what you get is
you get these innervating workarounds
like oh if we use time dilation if we
went really fast then it wouldn't be
that fast can you explain the word
innovating please you mean as in
Innovation or is this er no innervating
what's that means to to lessen in
um potency to decrease to to sort of
discourage and
you know as long as I have to do things
that don't involve me cruising to new
planets and taking in the VIS is like oh
it would be your great great to the 12
000th power
grandchild who actually sees a new plan
that's not gonna work are you going to
open a wormhole or you're going to have
an alcubieri drive all of these sorts of
things discourage us and we know that
we're telling lies about it
and so we don't work on it you want to
know how to work on this
we're abandoning the one field that has
the chance of making us interplanetary
and I don't know what to do about it
because nobody sees this as the
emergency I do we'll get back to talking
to Eric in one minute but first I need
to tell you about Cozy earth look we
spend one third of Our Lives asleep you
do not want to spend 33 percent of your
existence inside of sheets that do not
make you feel amazing cozy Earth has the
best quality betting it's not just about
what you sleep on it is what you sleep
under and the quality of your sheets
make a massive difference to the quality
of your sleep sleep is the Ultimate Game
Changer and improving your sheets will
improve your Sleep Quality cozy Earth is
a premium bedding and loungewear Company
where they make the best quality bedware
the products are made from super soft
viscose from highly sustainable bamboo
temperature regulating so you'll sleep
cool all year round best of all they've
got a 10 year warranty on all of their
products that's how confident they are
that they'll last you can get an
exclusive 35 discount site-wide on
everything from cozy Earth by going to
cozyearth.com com slash modern wisdom
and using the code modern wisdom 35 a
check out cozier.com modern wisdom and
modern wisdom a checkout okay so let me
see if I can get the topology of what
you've said right
the fact that Mars is
Within Reach broadly
and chemical Rockets correct of current
technology of current physics and we do
it
hooray super hard we did it into
planetary right but your point is that
oh it seems like uh that is
insufficient
and also kind of like a false duck type
scenario where
we did it but we didn't actually do the
thing we needed to do so we may have
even been better off had the nearest
closest planet been two light years away
assume Mars didn't exist correct and
assume that Elon was still the Visionary
that we want him to be
and he didn't have a chemical rocket
company
I'd like to think that he would be
focused on physics
I would like to think that any of these
people would be focused on physics
take anybody with 11 figures
what is your allocation to building a
life raft to get humans out of here
you don't you haven't even thought about
it immediately you're going to think
technology well what kind of a hole
would I need it's like no
you need a Blackboard
you need blackboards and physicists who
are not afraid to do physics right now
we are destroying the fundamental
physics community at a rate that you
could not believe what's happening give
me the gossip from inside
for 39 years
we've been dominated by one community's
Madness and that Community is called
quantum gravity
String Theory or M Theory
it changed what we were researching it's
it's cardinal sin is not about String
Theory it's not about quantum gravity it
changed the questions that met defined
what it meant to be a fundamental
physicist
so if I say to you how many generations
of matter are there
I don't know you don't know that it's
three because we don't talk about that
all the time anymore
or if I say do you know why why is
matter chiral you wouldn't know about
that or if I said what's the nature of
the cortic potential for the Higgs field
or why is there a yukawa coupling in one
case in a minimal coupling somewhere
else all of the real physics questions
that would cause
progress got
subtly replaced between 1984 and like
1987. and then we had questions like how
do we quantize gravity
and that became this oh that is the
ultimate question well it's it's not
that's that's just wrong this comes out
of Bryce DeWitt this comes out of a guy
who in 1952 went with his wife to the
Tata Institute of fundamental research
in Bombay then wrote an essay for
something called the Gravity Research
Foundation that was about anti-gravity
and they he was supposed to write an
essay and then he said well to get
anti-gravity what you'd really need to
do is to do quantum gravity and for 70
years we've been trying to do quantum
gravity and it's an abject failure
and the physicists at the at the helm
changed the questions the official
questions should sound something like
this why are there three generations of
matter why is it flavor chiral what is
the nature in the origin of the Higgs
mechanism
why are we in one comma three dimensions
and what is with su3 cross su2 cross U1
which is a bunch of symmetries and why
does it seem to represent on a 16
dimensional space with the observed
quantum numbers that may not mean a lot
to you but I guarantee you if there are
physicists in the audience they're
getting pissed off right now because
they allowed their their subject to be
dragged away from our real questions for
reasons that are unclear and put in the
service of these questions that can't be
answered and we can't even question them
39 years into this complete train wreck
that is the community that could build
the life raft what is so seductive about
Quantum everything quantum gravity yeah
it allows for toy problems so that you
can not do your
work on the world that we have and you
can say well the world that we have is
too complicated so I created this fake
world over here that's not in four
dimensions it's in two Dimensions it's
not in lorencian signature it's in
euclidean signature it's not the full
gauge group uh it's just su2 and I've
changed all the parameters and then I
say and I've made some minor incremental
progress in that fake world and then
everybody claps
and meanwhile
10 years later you don't even remember
what the particles are that are present
in the universe you don't even remember
the the standard model of particle
theory and this is a very real effect
today's physicists a lot of the young
ones are completely ignorant about the
physical world they could not find the
men's or women's room at CERN if their
life depended on them
yeah so it seems like
a hijacking of attention and focus
from
difficult problems
to from useful difficult problems to
useless or less useful
easier problems but if you try to talk
about the real problems you can't get
engagement and they will say it is well
maybe people just aren't interested in
your ideas I was like yeah but you're
not listening to so far as I can tell
everybody who comes from outside with an
interesting new idea isn't being
listened to it's not personal
and we also have a responsibility this
is like it's a really crazy part
we doomed Humanity
like Francis Crick
who was a co-discover of the
three-dimensional structure of DNA was a
physicist
Edward Teller was a physicist stanislav
ulam was a geometer
we doomed Humanity on Earth
and then we're treating science as if oh
it's a series of puzzles
well what do you want to work on today
well I don't want to be arrogant I'll
just work on this tiny little problem
and I'm just thinking like do do you not
feel any basic responsibility after
Hiroshima Nagasaki and kovid
just how crazy are you is that you know
we've spoken about the interplanetary
challenge right and the fact that
physics needs to make some progress in
order to facilitate that if we're going
to do it yeah is in your opinion
forgetting the fact that chemical
Rockets right limitations all that sort
of stuff
is going into planetary as useful is it
the highest priority the highest
priority
you'll you cannot stabilize this place
just imagine every communalist dream
came true
we turned away from fossil fuels towards
a the greenest New Deal you could
possibly imagine
all billionaires realized the errors of
their ways and contributed their money
to bring up the poorest of the poor
AI was as beneficial as it could be and
only helped Humanity to live it straight
just go full
wild Pollyanna optimism
you still can't stabilize it why
um
too many people
say more not for long population rates
both rights at the moment we're talking
at totally different scales
I'm telling you that with
crispr cas9 with the teller ulam design
ivg
AVG
you know ivg IVF but being able to use
from any other sure yep uh so I was
trying to I was trying to think uh in a
different context
foreign
people
what happens when you distribute the
coronavirus because everybody's had it
you've had it
I got an antibody test and I had it but
never felt it okay yeah so you have this
this pla platform this virus viral
platform that's spread all over the
world and you have the ability to edit
it
are you telling me that people aren't
going to figure out how to come up with
fun viruses and gain a function projects
and people are going to be able to do
these uh you know
polymerase Chain Reaction I think was
taught in my daughter's High School
are you familiar with uh Nick bostrom's
balls from the urn analogy yeah vaguely
yeah so for the people that don't know
you can imagine that you you haven't
earned and each time that you make
technological progress you pick a ball
out and you don't know what color some
are white perfectly good yep some are
gray bit a good bit of bad and some are
all the way down to black and black is
permanent unrecoverable collapse right
and the unrecoverable bit is important
no
and each time we just keep picking out
balls so my take on it is
there's already too much leverage too
much leverage too little wisdom too many
people suppose that you once said uh we
are Gods but for the wisdom we're just
shitty gods
I don't know if it's the second part but
um
you know I I guess when I heard the
story about this kid who scavenged the
americium from all of these smoke
detectors in Brooklyn and built a
self-sustaining nuclear reactor from
these tiny little radioactive strips you
don't know what people's creativity is
you know
I found it fascinating when I was
growing up that I was the only kid who
knew that gunpowder or black powder was
75 potassium nitrate 10 sulfur and 15
carbon like you could just make it
you know
and
you know that's the recipe and
that that just blew my mind that the
rate limiting step was that
people didn't know that potassium
nitrate was saltpeter or where to get it
like meat tenderizer but
mostly we're saved from the stuff
because nobody's so sociopathic and
competent
that they go for these high leverage
attacks that's going to end
you know that was like what happened on
9 11. I always wanted to know why were
little kids allowed to go into the
cockpit of a plane you used to be able
to meet the pilot I remember meeting
them I remember doing it yeah so that's
where we are now is is that we've got
all this High leverage stuff and you're
going to see nuclear proliferation
eventually you're going to get some
despot backed into a corner
who says well this is my only move well
I mean
for the nuclear concernists out there at
least what I know wouldn't that be all
of us everybody is concerned but for the
people that are
nuclear war is a genuine X risk
permanent unrecoverable collapse you can
set them all off unless there's like 10
to 100 times more than we think that we
have which there very well could be
um
it seems difficult for it to be
permanent unrecoverable collapse
for me as a true true true actress may I
say something yeah this is ridiculous
it's bad enough
that it would completely transform Life
as we know it you'd agree that
absolutely absolutely
it's time it's time to get serious about
things we can actually do and the most
interesting thing is that nobody's
interested
in interplanetary physics
I I just I've never seen anything like
it
interplanetary physics would be physics
in service of us becoming interplanetary
or is there something specific about the
way that planets figure together no no
it's it's about
let me give you an analogy that's more
than an analogy assume that somebody
hands you
a physical paper map
an enormous one okay
and you're trying to navigate it on this
table that we're we have here you're
starting to do Motions like this where
you're moving the paper across the table
you know to get from Los Angeles to
Fresno California if it's at the right
scale
and it might take you a long time to do
that
okay but now you have somebody trained
on an iPad what are they gonna do
well they might do that but that's not
the key thing they're going to do
they're going to do what is called multi
multi-touch gestures
and the one that you're thinking of
should be pinched to zoom
so the most natural way to do this is to
treat it not as if it's a paper map but
a stack of paper maps and you want to go
to the one with a different scale if if
you were doing this on an iPad that was
mirroring this the key point is is that
the paper map doesn't have an extra
Dimension to play with but the pinch to
zoom dimension
is a scale Dimension so imagine what you
did instead was you looked at your house
you pinch to zoom out
you then do this motion or whatever it
is to get to your friend's house and
then when you land there
you expand it again
imagine that you only know about paper
maps but your adversary has an iPad
that's what I'm worried about we're not
looking for pinch to zoom
what would that be in this
um well I claim that there are going to
be 10 extra coordinates and
four of them
are pinched to zoom
and six of them are what I would call
um
Shear to tilt so imagine that you have a
copy of a picture of of the Leaning
Tower of Pisa on your iPad
you should be able to do something in
paint which changes the angle
right so if you go into Ms paint there's
this little thing that allows you to
change by a particular area but you
could do that as a gesture where
so my claim is if you have four
dimensions of time and X Y and Z of
space
you have pinch to zoom on all of all
four of those and then for any two
Dimensions like x and z
you have Shear to tilt
so the first are the four rulers and the
next are the six protractors and that's
something called a symmetric two tensor
or a metric which Einstein knew all
about but he only chose one through his
equations and he let all the other ones
lie Fallout and my claim is I don't
think that's where we are I think that
interplanetary physics is going to
involve moving from what we called space
time to something called The Observers
which contains pinch to zoom and Shear
to tilt
and you want to get off this planet
you're not going to get there using
general relativity and you're not going
to get there using the standard model
it's time to take your pacifier out of
your mouth and go back to doing real
physics
I think if we were serious about this
we would be struggling with the physics
of the world in which we live not toy
models we'd be taking massive risks and
listening to people from various
perspectives who haven't failed or have
not been
invited to fully explain their ideas and
we'd be looking for things that would be
new new variables new ways of working
with the world that allowed us to do
things that would previously considered
inconceivable so if you if you look at
1911 which is when I think Rutherford
first starts talking about the neutron
as a hypothesis
it's 41 years later we have the hydrogen
bomb
we can do incredible things that are not
possible
yet because we don't know the framework
and my claim is
if you imagine somebody used to paper
maps being put on an iPad
and not knowing about multi-touch vet
gestures that is pretty much an exact
analogy of what happens when you do too
much general relativity is that you
start to think in general relativistic
terms as if that's the last word
Einstein would never have put up with
that that's a question you've mentioned
Einstein a couple of times today
the most famous physicist of all time
how different do you think the landscape
of physics would be had Einstein lived
for another decade
just how good was he
he was that good
it was the rare situation in which the
man and the myth are roughly at the
right level
the same level
I don't think you could solve the puzzle
of theoretical physics
and a final Theory before the mid-1970s
we just didn't know enough
um
in particular quarks in 1968.
you needed confirmation because they're
not obvious
in the world they're stuck inside of
protons and neutrons and if you thought
that protons and neutrons were
fundamental
you wouldn't be in contention I would
say that the first time you could really
guess the answer would be around 1975.
and I don't think Einstein was in a
position to guess the answer I think he
was very caught up in a Romanian
framework which is that you deal only
with length angle and the curvature of
the space in which you live there's sort
of a more modern viewpoint on this that
he could have understood and I don't
know to what extent he showed any
recognition of it but a lot of his
thinking was really well
suited for the world in which he lived
where he could do these thought
experiments in his mind about
falling elevators or train cars or
whatever
um
you know duroc
was every bit Einstein's equal
we don't know how to interact with the
rock because duroc was so strange and he
you know Einstein kept throwing off
wisdom at an incredible rate if you read
ideas and opinions or out of my later
years you have an idea of just
what a sage this person was even when
he's screwing things up and making
mistakes he's it's all sage-like Dirac
was the singular
human being and occasionally he says
something about
life like I think when he was given a
Nobel Prize
I think shared with Schrodinger he's
given two speeches and he uses his
lunchtime speech to talk about the bond
market and the importance that's crazy
uh and the importance of using the
toolkit of
physics within any sphere that is
numbers based
but we don't really know much about
duroc's views on Humanity we know about
his beautiful
aesthetic of of the quantum he gave the
quantum poetry
and
I think right now it's up to us they're
not here right now it's time to make
guesses
I'm very partial to an example which
happened on the Wheel of Fortune program
fold this into The Cutting Edge of
physics all right come on sure I'm
waiting okay
there's a guy named Ken Wilson who's
discouraged all modern physicists from
making guesses about the ultimate Theory
because he taught us that you can only
observe the world at the energy scale
that you're at so you and I are in a
classical world we don't see the quantum
yeah
on Wheel Of Fortune
there was there was a puzzle and it said
okay phraser expression there's one
apostrophe in the first word with three
letters
and it's a long answer and person
guesses are and there are no r's
and
um
then I think that it goes to the next
woman I think she guesses n
and oh yes there's one n and she says
okay I'd like to solve
and the host looks at her incredulously
like well it's I I guess you could try
to solve and she says and and I will
always remember this I've got a good
feeling about this and it was right
okay
you never guessed that there was enough
information for a solve
whatever we have is what we've got it's
time to solve the puzzle what would that
look like
uh ask somebody else I try to solve this
I've Got a Theory but Peter white has a
theory I'd like to hear what the string
theorists think their theory is I'd like
to understand where asymptotic safety is
everybody who's got a theory whether
it's David Deutsch or Julian Barbour or
Garrett Lisi needs to come to a
conference somebody needs to hold a
conference and say who can solve this
puzzle let's put the Sword in the Stone
and let's let everybody try to pull it
out because now is the tongue
and the idea that we're not doing this
and that we're letting this community
that has run itself into the ground
continue to adjudicate what is physics
it's like you boys haven't really done
anything
in N years you're not the Arbiters of
what is science and what isn't you
you've allowed this madness to creep
into your University departments you're
signing loyalty OS I have physics
professors telling me that their boss is
some Dean who writes to them about what
they what they posted on social media
it's like no you're the boss you the
professors are the soul of the
University
stop sucking your thumb stand up for
what it is that you're supposed to be
standing up for which is excellence in
research kick the people out who don't
belong there and invite the people in
who do and let's get on with it it's
just I couldn't be more angry about
anything else in the world how can you
how can you take the Lifeboat community
the the only community that can get us a
way out of here and run it into the
ground I like to turn the Lifeboat
community
it's it's time to save everybody and
we've we've got huge
responsibilities we carry a lot of
responsibility for getting everybody
into this mess and now we've got to
offer everybody a way out
yeah it seems I don't know I I don't
know the inner workings or the
machinations of the physics World
um but the first time I ever spoke to
Sabine hosenfelder she explained to me
that physics is as much about politics
as it is about physics in bad eras that
becomes more true yes sabina's entire
career has taken place inside of the
stagnation and she's like one of these
truth-telling people I think she's
basically truthful I disagree with a lot
of stuff that I I don't like that she I
think she does which is a disservice to
the community
but she is truthful that this community
is off the rails
moving from physics to something that
you mentioned that poetry sure your
cover photo on Twitter was the first
thing that we actually ever connected
about long long long time ago and I'd
just been to the Sagrada Familia tell me
so I went for the first time to a
wedding a friend's wedding that he was
holding on the outskirts and it was very
enjoyable and
I had known about this building I had
read about it I had seen all of the
videos and it's your cover photo first
off why and then secondly what does it
mean to you what does this Sagrada
Familia mean to you
I'm dying to hear
obviously we know it's important in my
life I don't know whether it had an
importance in yours
Beyond Beauty no it has no greater
meaning to me than that but one of the
lessons that I did learn was
that quote about uh
Humanity will flourish when men plant
trees under which they will never sit
something along those lines and that's
the first time that I've ever seen
a purely joyful expression
architecturally artistically
that was created
with the intense intent purpose that
that would be the end goal that this is
a
where are we at now in construction 70
years nearly 100 now how many I don't
know but it's a lot long still going
yeah so and it's not done and I think
it's and we can't even figure out what
his vision is so we've allowed other
people to put their Bishop in and yeah
because there's only one of him cowdy
okay the ceiling of that thing to me is
Transcendence
you can't even believe it's real
you know that
there are things in this world
that remind you of the Transcendent in
all of us that it's possible
you know
um
I can think of particular pieces of
music or
poems or pieces of architecture I was
just inside the Blue Mosque
um in Istanbul
which is you know a few feet from Aya
Sofia and the interior of these two
structures just
are mind-blowing
um
and La cigarette for me I mean these are
religions that I'm not a part of
if you're talking about the sacred
family and you have a skylights
to heaven
how better to honor the Creator whether
the Creator exists or not
than with
genius and and elegance and Grace and
humility and and arrogance and
everything that went into that ceiling
that ceiling is like nothing else I've
ever seen
um
and you know you can touch you know Sam
Harris is famous for saying that you can
either learn how to meditate or I can
give you a few micrograms of the
substance you're going to have a
profound experience
well okay
um just getting back from Sal Miguel and
the Azores
you could take LSD or DMT or or you
could go to San Miguel I mean it's just
crazy that that that there is that much
Beauty on Earth and
I guess that space is something that I
wanted people to understand when I named
the show the portal and people did not
understand it wasn't intended to be a
show
it's intended to be a search for the
actual portal out of here it's an
attempt to find
pinch to zoom
I believe that we are not doomed here
but that we have developed this very
weird focus on psychology we
to challenge Einstein is almost seen as
arrogance
and yet if Einstein is to survive as a
legacy it's only going to be because
somebody basically
undermined general relativity status as
a fundamental Theory
because we're not going to make it and
I'm trying to remind people
in a world that now like you can look up
on Twitter
say lone genius Theory
people don't believe in the lone genius
Theory
um
well then what was Gowdy
what was the rock what was Einstein what
was yang
what was Emmy nerder some somebody tell
me why I have all of these lone Geniuses
in my life
and aren't we supposed to be doing that
and thinking that that's admirable I
think we're supposed to be building
this the theory that can realize that
the ceiling of lacrada Familia is a
portal
we're supposed to inspire ourselves with
beauty and luxury we're not supposed to
consume it to pig out for status reasons
we're supposed to get ourselves into a
state where we can dream at an
interplanetary level
a lot of the things that we've spoken
about today are to do with cerebral
horsepower cognition yeah they're
difficult things that need to be done in
the head and yet you're talking here
about the Transcendent you're talking
about something which is embodied which
is spiritual by whichever definition of
the word you want to use
do you find in yourself as somebody who
does rely on cerebral horsepower for a
lot of the things that you try to do and
presumably takes pride in your ability
to have
workout problems have thoughts do you
feel attention in yourself between the
the Transcendent the relinquishing the
embodied and the cerebral the cognitive
the uh purposeful on that side you know
I have a dumb expression which I don't
use in public and I'm sure I'll be I'll
be uh castigated for it yeah brilliant
but it's head heart and loins
if it doesn't speak to your head heart
and your loins leave it for someone else
what's that mean how do you enact that
you have to try to realize that these
things have to be balanced and tempered
you don't want to live by your heart
just every time you know you see a
daffodil blowing its seeds into the wind
you'll be transported and you'll stop
paying your electric bills and you don't
want to be led around by your loins
that's not going to end well and you
don't want to be led around by your head
too because then you'll get yourself
into one of these cul-de-sacs and you
won't even realize that you can't think
your way out of it you were given all of
these facilities and motivations how do
you pull yourself from head to hot
well
you you brought this guitar
Lady it's just on your right grab it
show it to everybody
so I don't
I I do not play the guitarle
I don't think anybody actually
technically does it's like a guitar
that's too small for your fingers yes
you've got your pixel in it
so
you take some piece of music that
actually means something to you right
and
one thing that I remember hearing when I
was growing up was this
[Music]
so this is the astorious of Isaac
albanes it was originally written for
piano
and
you see sorts of these things on Ood
where you have a tremolo you've got two
two fingers playing the open B string
and then you've got this melody which is
played with the thumb
oh
[Music]
so the combination of these things
produces this different effect
foreign
[Music]
get my fingers in there
started thinking about okay well that's
a great effect what if we tried to write
and to create using the same idea I
started
okay so uh
[Music]
so that's not the same song but it's
using some of the same techniques about
just getting these things to ring out
and to get the melody going on the
Baseline
and then you have to forget
this now you know if I was able to play
this properly and I'm sorry if I'm
embarrassing myself you're trying to do
this thing where you're
you're recognizing that the Transcendent
lives
in
particular structures that they elicit
this feeling and that we have this
opportunity to go back and forth between
the analytic description if I'm thinking
about this I can't really feel it and if
I'm feeling it I can't really figure out
how to use it or think about it or
compose with it and so
um you know to me what we're trying to
do is we're trying to
um
camp and D camp
well that spoke to my head and my loins
but it didn't speak to my heart
or that spoke to two out of three
we need ultimately to be fully embodied
and that's a challenge and we have to we
either accept the challenge or we don't
accept the challenge
and we have to go back and forth between
these lenses you can't necessarily
be in the same you know if you see your
child and you're a physician a surgeon
you could see your child as a bunch of
tissue hooked up to itself you know
and that's important if you're hiking
and you're in a bad spot you actually
have to do an operation on your child
but it's a terrible way to
put your child to sleep when you're
reading a bedtime story is that a
is there a challenge that people are
facing at the moment with
an over-reliance on a brain-based
economy
a unlimited amount of information at
your fingertips with Wikipedia and
Chachi PT
for them to struggle to
find something Transcendent when it can
be broken down into its component parts
and explained by somebody who
understands the child as a connection of
ligaments organs and blood vessels as
opposed to as the beautiful progeny of
the person looking at them
well keep in mind that there are people
who can weave poetry
through their description of something
very technical Hermann vile for example
wrote in a very Olympian fashion about
abstract algebra we talked about the
homosexuality of certain symbols
affiliating with themselves you know
completely crazy arithmetic
and um
you know there are people who just write
beautifully uh I think that Jim Watson
who may be a son of a on many
fronts is one of the great writers in
the English language if you read the
double helix it's an incredible
narrative uh from the most one of the
most memorable first sentences to to the
conclusion
we need
the Carl Sagan's
to animate our head and our hearts
at the same time
do you think there is an over-reliance
on head at the moment
I'm worried that our head heart and
loins are all disengaged
so what do you use if you're not using
any of those I use them all no but what
are the people using who are not using
those uh they're not watching what's
happening to them they're being
denatured by their phones
your phone is not a phone
it is a very it's an environment
you know you pick it up and suddenly
you're you're someplace that you don't
realize isn't relative to your physical
surroundings like you get very angry
that you get a text message while you're
driving and you try responding to it
well you're going 45 miles an hour in a
several hundred pound
or a thousand pound vehicle
you've lost track of where you are
um
our phone is you know and
I talk to people about the crisis in
pornography
the only fans movement the pornographic
stuff that you're seeing
people are not getting easily excited
and aroused
inside of any kind of context like the
erotic is taking it on the chin I think
I think that's really important to
remember that eroticism for example is
at least a combination of the loins in
the head and and at best the heart as
well
what you're starting to see is people
can't actually derive excitement
from normal stimuli that has to do with
falling in love or having children or
you know so you're talking about an Ever
escalating stimulus that people require
to get the same arousal response and
they can't
yeah Mary Harrington calls this one of
her three laws of pornodynamics it's the
law of FAP entropy that whatever you
start out wanking to will get
progressively more extreme over time
well
what's the cure for that something
high-end
you could just try to do it all in loins
show me something where my psychogenic
arousal gets greater and greater because
I've never seen that and holy cow is
that far out
or you could say you know it's more like
a Cobb Douglas utility function you're
going to have to bring this down to my
level multiple inputs in other words if
I could offer you only food or only
water
that would not work
you'd rather if you have a lot of food
have a little water to complement it
because that water becomes that much
more valuable or if you have a ton of
liquids and you have no nourishment you
probably want really value a little bit
of food well in my opinion part of what
we need is we need more more things that
reward us when we're integrating rather
than where when we're extremizing
get back to that discussion about uh
technology sort of not only fracturing
our attention but also fracturing our
experience there seems to be a
wistfulness not just in the dating realm
but in the experiential realm for a
bygone time where we felt connected to
the things that we do yeah and
it's interesting for someone of my age
I'm 35 so I'm like slap bang in the
middle of the Millennials right so I
remember a time before ubiquity of
iPhones before internet but there was a
Like There's A Whimsy of childhood in
any case and me being able to
tear those two apart is kind of
difficult but I definitely think that
when I read history when I read um Ryan
holiday for instance and I think about
Xeno obsidium walking around the stoopoe
clay where I've been and I'm there and I
I think about the degree of connection
to the experience
what is technology and what are our
smartphones doing to our ability to
connect so they're changing our our wet
wear
we're not
if you can have 12
life-changing experiences in the space
of a minute and none of them are yours
what do you think that's going to do to
your mind
you know at some point I was in an
Oculus situation I was deep underwater
and a blue whale swam past me
well none of that actually happened but
it felt like it did
or you know that you can do this uh
nuclear explosion on Henderson Island in
Oculus
that's just a more immersive phone
and
look
you have to be you know that's one of
the things about La Sagrada Familia
you go in there and it's real
you see the Grand Canyon and it is
actually Grand
you know you there's certain things that
don't easily live up to their billing
I think I went to pamukale in Turkey
years ago which pamuk means cotton and
Calais I guess castles or the cotton
castles of mineral deposits and they
would form these pools
and there weren't enough pools and there
were way too many people so it was like
one of those moments where the tourists
have totally destroyed the natural
attraction
okay but I went into the Blue Mosque and
it was every bit as mind-blowing as it
was the last time I was there 30 years
ago it's the same way that I feel every
single time I step into the Vatican
every single every single time and I've
been there three times now I've been
there three times and it's just holy cow
well I shouldn't have said that anyway
um very good I didn't mean to uh
yeah you have to there have to be things
that you actually viscerally relate to
that stop you like the Bach Cello Suites
how many times have I heard the Box up
or a whole lot of love
can do it either way or You Shook Me All
Night Long you know that's holy You
Shook Me All Night Long
is
is a Transcendent song
it's less Transcendent if you see it as
part of a 60-second tick tock Montage no
because the Shema is transcended and
that'll fit right in there
all right yes
[Music]
yeah you who shook me all night long
that's prayer
yes You Shook Me All Night Long
you know if that doesn't move you you
need to check into some place
those four notes
recur in all of these songs that matter
it's basically Mary Had a Little Lamb
with Pho thrown in as well
you know and then I bring up this
example my wife was watching a film I
didn't want to watch it with some chick
flick and it all hovers around this one
scene where this guy drags this girl
into a uh a music store because he can't
afford a piano
I don't know you but I want you going up
to that fourth
all the more for that and I just I was
transfixed I couldn't could not continue
to do my calculations like what the hell
is this movie so those four notes is a
great place to ground yourself and
there's a reason that they work the
second note
brings up in your mind the uh
the thing called the fifth the dominant
chord the first note is spread between
the the tonic and the subdominant the
third note belongs to the tonic only and
the fourth note only belongs to the
subdominant and so this this idea that
Western Harmony revolves around these
ideas of the tonic the subdominant the
dominant
are carried by these notes so even if
you're not playing it on a chordal
instrument
that this pattern of four notes that
keeps recurring
grabs us because we know what the chords
are behind it
and it's basically Mary had a little
lamb or Proud Mary you know
but that's a great place to start for
Transcendence
let's check on something really simple
whether you're feeling it
oh and Dread
to emotions that I miss in my life say
more
so when I look up at the night sky I get
it in equal dosages oh good uh you know
when it's good I've been out to Joshua
Tree
taking an edible
didn't need the edible at all that was
unnecessary amplification you know we're
having this discussion in the middle of
the perseids meteor shower
no
I highly recommend get yourself to a
place where there's no light pollution
and lay on your back right before Daniel
you'll have a blast oh and but the ah on
the dread is is very much that yes and
uh I don't know it makes you feel
insignificant in a way I think that
keeps your ego small and helps to resend
to your do you want your ego small
uh have you been told that was a good
thing
I've been told that it's a good thing
I would say for me
remembering finitude and not
insignificance but
the
temporary nature
about time here the vastness of what is
going to go on the things that have come
before the things that will come after
the scale yeah I think that that it
grounds me I struggled to
get into my head to describe the thing
that is almost exclusively in heart and
lines and uh
it makes me feel good when I do that and
yet I find myself I've got emails to do
I heard this term the other day John
Lovell Warrior Poet Society said the
tyranny of the urgent
and
I love that the tyranny of the
urgent
you're familiar with this concept of
bathos no
the alternation between the Transcendent
and the mundane and the pressing you
know like okay
We Will Conquer The Cosmos but I have to
pick up my dry clean
um
yeah I think that there is that that
tyranny but I also want to just talk
about
arrogance and humility
I meet too many people who have won
without the other
I see all these discussions online about
so-and-so has this beautiful epistemic
humility or somebody else's uh you know
preposterously arrogant or whatever
and I I sort of sit and wonder at this
discussion
you want both
what is humility without arrogance
well
you know who I think actually had this
in kind of pretty decent balance that
was on display for the world to see was
uh
khabib nurmagomedov
what an unbelievably good example right
so well tell me tell me how it lands for
you
like khabib is very very high on the
list of people that I would love to
speak to and you hear that khabib listen
khabib if anybody in Dagestan has got
khabib's email address please tell him
to get in touch okay this is fascinating
to me so the more
I'll I'll do a timeline of it so Conor
McGregor very seductive very obviously
seductive
working class the Irish hate to be told
that they're a part of the UK they're
not they're near you know close enough
it's like an adopted son type thing okay
and I'm thinking God this guy's like a
savant of war and Artistry as he's
coming up and then he beats Chad Mendes
uh and it's a a war as a fight and then
he's crying and then he does the other
side of it and he's doing uh with Edo
portal he's balancing in the middle of
maybe Vegas or or California somewhere
on a uh walking rail on its side rail
and he's I think Nate Diaz accused him
of playing touch butt with that dork in
the park
um and he's doing handstands and he's
got this sort of fluidity to him right
and then there's this amazing interview
that was clipped and put in perfectly of
a journalist reciting back to Conor what
he said before the Aldo fight and he
said uh at the press conference I I saw
his right hand shaking that was a subtle
tell for me he's going to overload with
that right hand and when he thinks I
will be that I will not I will create
gaps within that octagon he will fall
into those gaps and that is when I will
strike and then there's a clip of him
backstage before he's about to fight and
he's bouncing backwards and forwards in
that sort of long karate stance that he
does and he steps back and he throws
that left hook practicing and they
placed it in time with the fight amazing
and it's the same move
and this guy says you said these things
recites that thing post fight
how'd you do that
how do you do that and Conor talks about
if you have The Bravery enough to speak
it and the courage enough to be able to
pursue it
and I'm just enthralled by this
guy I put got put onto a reality TV show
in my 20s that we had no internet no
contact with friends or family or any
sort of muse and it turned out that
while I was there I think it was Rafael
dosanos
um was injured so I was terrified I was
gonna miss McGregor's fight because
that's how inspiring it was to me
and then does this this talk of this guy
this other fighter unbeaten undefeated
and it's the Bane Batman type scenario
at least that's the model that I had in
my mind and I'm like you know
you've got the almost the rocky uh
versus uh who was the Russian guy that
he's training for in the fight no
who's the Russian guy that kind of
fights
the uh Rocky fight sorry
yes I'm draghav so
it's almost that right you've got this
training in the mountains and chopping
wood
um and then
there's the dolly kind of throws the
dolly and you start to see that was the
first time I really took notice of
khabib
and you remember that video send me
location send me location just tell me
where
send me location and there's a number of
tribute videos called the locations but
with a K uh about khabib I'm like
hell like this is this guy's
something else
sky is real correct so Connor McGregor
was spread between real and fake
right the Showmanship was it was a part
of
it was backed up
particularly by his striking by his
ability to sense his opponent
sort of almost using your right an
antenna yeah yeah
um
but I really believe that in part
trying to get into your opponent's head
with somebody
I I really wonder whether westerners
have any idea of what happens in places
like Central and Eastern Europe when you
start talking about somebody's mother
you know
like are you you start I
I had this really bad cultural reaction
which is that there are people who are
bought into the whole
trash talking thing
you know and it if it had been like I
don't know Conor McGregor versus I don't
know how to print as a child sonan or
something like that yeah
it's a fair game yeah they're both
they're both accepting the game
and with khabib I just had this other
thought of like have you never met
anyone from Dagestan before yeah
like anyone from Dagestan it's not just
khabib
sorry it's just you know it's so bad
have you ever done improv no well
inadvertently in improv classes uh
there's something called punking the
game okay uh and let's say that we're in
a circle and we're supposed to whoosh we
pass energy around whoosh and you can go
boing and it goes back the other way and
you can like send it across and stuff
there's only one rule one rule is don't
punk the game punking the game is ah
like not playing by the rules game
rejection yes
and what you see is uh Conor playing a
game of tennis and he keeps on serving
this ball across
and
the boys 100 From khabib's perspective
not only does the ball not come back
across the net he doesn't even have the
racket in his hand
you know he's there he's got to be there
there's obligations to be done
and it was that
series of press conferences yeah that
really made me fall in love with khabib
and then how
it gets me emotional thinking about you
thinking about his tribute to his father
I'm telling you I can't see it from
Conor's perspective
of why you would behave in that way like
two seconds facing this guy it's not a
question of fear it's a question of
respect
well maybe I just don't get it but I
spend enough time I have spent enough
time
in I don't know the north of India or
the center of turkey or places in Egypt
or Ukraine or Russia wherever
you don't
I I can tell the Internet it's going to
completely tell me I don't get it you
don't do this stuff you just don't it's
like I can't explain to people who are
convinced that the internet is the gift
to prove that dunking and dragging is
man's highest function there's so much
stuff you don't do and this whole move
towards like anonymity and
let's make fun of everybody and
everything because mockery is good yeah
this way this this is the direction to
Madness
I certainly think that Peterson said
this a while ago one of the main
problems with Twitter is it's driven the
proximate price of being a prick down to
zero
sure in the combination of real people
and unnamed accounts and bought farms
and the inability to work out whether
it's being said in Earnest or set in a
or whether it's been coordinated so that
000 people go off at once on the exactly
the same point
getting back to the issue of arrogance
and and uh humility what is khabib
competent
unwavering
humble
he's both arrogant and humble
and you have to look at the move that he
does
when you compliment him
what does he do
alhamdulillah right or masha'allah or
something with the name Allah in it
it's like I give you this praise oh no
no no it's not for me it's for the God
all for my father
or or for my father right and so this
issue about this is a this is a
beautiful thing when you when you have
Muslim friends is that they learn
to deflect
all of this positivity
out if they're getting it
they deflect it so that they don't keep
it and they don't become insufferable on
the other hand if they're extraordinary
what they do they know that they're
extraordinary at what they do khabib is
under no Illusions as to how good he is
he set the highest standards tomorrow
night I'm gonna smash your boy
he is simultaneously
you said competent it just wasn't fair
to him
he's Way Beyond competent
and
you know I
I guess I just want people to realize
that you need arrogance to stand up
against insuperable odds
and you need humility to stop your
arrogance from driving you insane and to
keep asking that people be constantly
humble
is an affront to what we are as humans I
really don't grasp it
you need that deep humility 100 percent
but so many people need arrogance in
order to take on the challenges that
they they could if you took the world
seriously you'd never take on those
challenges if you were just humble
um yes
yes this uh my favorite clip one of my
favorite clips of khabib post fighting
post Korea uh he's doing an interview
and talking about the training camps the
gym that he looks after and some of the
fighters that are there and apparently I
think they train six days or six and a
half days a week and he tells them they
need to get up and some of the guys
complain and he says is okay you can you
go home your mum she'll tuck you into
bed at night she will cook you dinner
and tomorrow
you'll be comfortable
but that's not why you're here
put that coffee down
do you know coffees for closers ah yes
yes good reference your your name's
Levine
he calls yourself a Salesman you son of
a
I just love I really really love this
I I had a conversation last week and uh
I was told a quote
self-love is holding yourself to a
higher standard than anybody else
you know I'll be honest with you I get
tired of these things I think that
there's a lot of men in particular
looking for simple answers
and all of these things fall flat for me
it they're front loaded because they
simplify things right imagine that
that's what all that self-love was well
then I'd have I'd have a definition yeah
but it's not going to work and I think
that this is one of the things that um
I don't know how to fight exactly is
that we're in a world that's convinced
that the truth must be simple and all of
these simple truths don't survive
the collider that is modern social media
so I don't disagree the problem with a
truth which is boundlessly complex is
that functionally it's useless so that's
what and I'm so glad you made this point
that's the puzzle we're now in a world
where to do the Nuance is to get
yourself Tangled Because the Internet is
not friendly to Nuance on the other hand
to say something simply and crisply
leads you into
disappointing everyone who's believed in
you and you know we were talking before
a little bit about Christopher Hitchens
yes tell me about your thoughts on hitch
I asked Sam this question Sam spent a
good bit of time with him what would the
modern culture be like if hitch was
still alive
hitch I think would have been forced to
either self-incinerate
or
adapt
and I'm not sure what you would have
done what self-incineration in this
context
one of the things that makes Christopher
Hitchens a hero to so many people almost
oddly a secular Saint if you will is
that he held the promise that one could
simply stand
in some place that was reasonable
and hold forth from that simple
perspective like nope
there's nothing to Islam it is nonsense
it might be something he would say or
you might say
um
you know free speech is absolute and you
have every right to say anything you
want and I have every right to say and
the better ideas will prevail
now you watch what's happened with Sam
and this question of trump
Sam perceives Trump to be an asymmetric
existential threat
and was willing to go and back the idea
that the hunter Biden laptop story
might not
uh have benefited the election
and he's lost an enormous number of
people who otherwise agree with him and
now what's the reasoning the reasoning
and something oddly I first time I met
Sam I went on his show to warn him that
you can't just optimize for truth you
have to optimize I said I have four
variables I can't live without truth
meaning Fitness and Grace
so Trump is a fitness puzzle to Sam
which is if we allow Trump to destroy
the country in Sam's mind then we've
lost Fitness there's no there's no point
in being truthful
and then there's a question about what
is the meaning do you destroy the
meaning of a democracy when you hold
back information maybe you do maybe it
no longer feels like it's an actual
democracy
what is the graceful thing to do what is
the just and right thing to do
um
I am convinced that some of hitch's
positions
were attractive because he was using his
big brain to suggest that life could be
lived simply
if we were just strong enough of
character if we were clear enough of
thought we could espouse something like
free speech or Reason and it would be
enough
without requiring that we
hold it up to a higher power or that you
know you get caught in some very serious
situation where you're in an edge case
Free Speech does not exist in an
absolute form in under American law
it just doesn't really we we mentioned
Miller versus California which was a
sort of a follow-on decision to Memoirs
versus Massachusetts
um
you don't have a right
to broadcast pornography because
pornography does not enjoy First
Amendment
uh protection
now how do you discern that pornography
doesn't well the the justices claim that
it doesn't and there's a you know a
three Factor test for what is
pornography
which was I believe attenuated under
something called Memoirs versus
Massachusetts but that was not allowed
to stand you're not allowed to
necessarily endanger troop movements
uh by blabbing information in a war
you're not able to slander a libel there
are all sorts of adjustments to free
speech
and when you when you come at one of
these perspectives from an absolutist
frame of mind
you have to hope that you're not going
to meet the edge case a good example for
me was the Second Amendment
I noticed that many Second Amendment
types took an absolutist perspective
saying the right to keep and bear arms
will not be infringed and don't bother
me about a well-regulated militia I said
okay
I'm not going to talk to you about a
well-regulated militia my question is
should the Davy Crockett be sold at
Kmart and they would often say well
what's the Davy Crockett and I said well
it's about a hundred pound personal nuke
well first of all I was very
flabbergasted that a lot of gun
enthusiasts did not know that there was
a personal nuke developed by the United
States
but then immediately many of them saw
where this was going which is okay if
we're going to restrict personal nukes
at Kmart
then you've got your your foot in the
door the camel has its nose Under the
Tent it's a difference of degree not a
difference of kind all the way down
exactly so I think that personal nukes
have to be sold at Kmart because the
American population needs to keep parity
with the American Military
and then I say well do you realize what
you just said do you realize that you've
bounced out of your very simplified
framework
they don't
and this is partially the problem which
is that if you can't talk about taste
and trade-offs and balance because none
it's all squishy
then you have all of these people
running to these different Ultra
simplifications none of which work
there's a quote from one of my smartest
friends guinda
a dilemma of tweeting is that you're
aware of exceptions and conditions to
your statements but can't include them
without turning an elegant aphorism into
a clunky mess so you must choose between
writing tinead garbage or getting torn
apart by pedants and replies and quote
tweets
I've chosen to fail in a particular no
but this is this is really important
I'm failing how about you
depends what your goals are well but my
point to you is I don't think we're
meant to succeed here what's that mean
what's the criteria
was that a herd
what's the Criterion no sorry the person
who just said no a guy guy what he said
was
that you're aware of the trade-off and
there's no way out of the trade-off
I believe that there are ways out but
they have their own problems once you
start to understand all of the different
forces that are arrayed against you
you realize that if somebody chooses to
hyper focus on various things
they can effectively destroy your
credibility in general and you brought
up Wikipedia and I wanted to talk about
that an interesting thing that's
happening with it Wikipedia is the
difference between individual Wikipedia
entries
and Wikipedia entries on like a subject
or a plant
or a geographic place
so isn't it strange that if you were to
look up for example
um
pneumatic drill on Wikipedia there'd be
a huge technically accurate article
about
pneumatic drills constitutes it who
invented it right
and then you look up Jordan Peterson and
I guarantee you it's going to be a war
zone
and now you've you fuse these two things
together which is weaponized Wikipedia
and
factual Wikipedia
and this is like some really dangerous
new object and I always knew that
Wikipedia The Genius thing that it was
had a finite shelf life because it made
the Fatal flaw of using authoritative
sources as Bedrock truth
what happens when trolls get access to
bedrock sources what happens when the
state department or the Department of
Homeland Security or the intelligence
Community or people who hate you
that was
the headlines that happened after my
episode on Joe's show
were it was the weekend that somebody
had
nudged the definition of recession on
Wikipedia to no longer be two
consecutive quarters of negative GDP
growth
and
this was a Monday and it happened over
the weekend I mentioned it and all hell
break loose broke loose it had already
broken loose over the weekend and then
obviously anything Joe touches gets
Amplified to right my Heavens you're
like
okay so the
the definitions that we use I think
Shapiro calls it semantic overload
uh that's the Battleground ultimately
almost all tell me the frame and I'll
tell you the argument
like somebody will say
um
you know
is it worth stopping Donald Trump by
suppressing stories yes or no go
I was like well
first of all the question was
designed to subsume that we have to stop
Donald Trump now I might agree that with
that I believe maybe we should stop
Donald Trump
but you did make that the argument and
then you piled on a question on top of
it you subsume that within the frame and
so
more or less this is everything at the
moment which is if you can if you can
Define misgendering and dead naming
um you've won the argument we suppose
it's a world in which yeah so I'll give
you an example for the fledgling podcast
is out there when you first start doing
a podcast you're nervous that the guest
doesn't like you you're nervous that the
guest isn't interested in you that your
question sucks that your question
doesn't make sense and you're terrified
of Silence among
millions of other things did any of
those happen in this episode oh you've
been very welcoming how could I not
after you serenaded me with you get a
laylee
um it was a perfect aphrodisiac so what
you do and what I noticed with a lot of
young new podcasters is they do what uh
multiple choice offering so they'll ask
you a question Eric hmm
Trump 2024 what do you think is going to
happen is it going to be that and as
soon as you say is it and you then
create either a binary or a trinary of
options yeah you have now not only
you've restricted for the entire
universe of different things that you
could have come up with I don't know
whatever you're gonna say
I've given you two choices so it makes
it difficult for you to take a third
because you need to say no and why no
and why and then take record so you
often offer up this very narrow very
uni-dimensional landscape exactly and it
ruins the the conversation
it's funny Lex
makes assumptions in so many of his
frames that I unweave
but I think he gets like
some of the best out of me
as a guest and there's something about
unweaving
Lex's questions which I hate doing to
him because I want to just answer his
questions but on the other hand there's
something about the process of unweaving
the assumptions that actually benefits
some of our interactions so
I I think that there's a lot of this
just
grooming us grooving us to only think
about certain possibilities yeah and
what I don't know is how do you get
nuanced thought
to propagate at the second meme you need
to make it sexy well you know to an
extent I do this with acronyms and the
acronyms have taken off
but then there's a different population
that gets very angry which is why are
you allowed to create
we're allowed to create these memes with
the distracted boyfriend you know but
you're not allowed to create an acronym
to make a concept sticky so what we're
in is some sort of
Warfare for mindshare
and
I'll be honest
I'm not seeing high level
interactions the way I was five years
ago between people what's happened
I think that they've
done a pretty good job of disconnecting
us you remember the old data and Society
report where you looked at chains of
Association and the whole game was to
tie everyone back to Milo ianopoulos or
something I so I got to interject I go
to Qatar to do this debate about
masculinity about six months ago and
they put up on one of the segments I was
pro-traditional masculinity and there
was a gentleman on the other side and
they said uh here is a montage you have
some unspeakable people that represent
masculinity and there was Joe Rogan and
John Peterson and blah blah blah blah
blah but the first person was Milo
yiannopoulos I said look
if you have brought me to the Middle
East to defend Milo yianopolis I did you
have brought the wrong person I'm like
you know that we need to shift that get
that to one side Milo can go over there
do you see his debate with Destiny that
he did a couple of weeks ago maybe three
months ago now
Milo looked like
a old touring singer in a rock band
still doing the shows but can't hit the
high notes anymore and he The Whimsy
yeah and that sort of
playful Jester Joker kind of game
gamesmanship had been abandoned in place
of bottom of the Barrel backbiting in
genuine emotional sniping
and then Destiny said after he's been
pushed and pushed and pushed for 90
minutes yeah he says to Destiny uh
uh back in the olden times they would
have left your kind on the side of a
hill a hill to die
and Destiny said well I think that the
gays would have been left there first
Milo said well I don't think that you
can tell whether a baby is going to like
dick when it comes out or not
Destiny said well you'd know all about
young boys liking dick wouldn't you wow
and it broke Milo it broke his brain so
what sorry what was that and no one had
any sympathy because for 90 minutes he'd
called Destiny's wife a public
flashlight he'd said everything under
the sun
why are we dealing with these people
because it is entertainment it is mental
masturbation it
a story about people
will always be more seductive to a
broader group than a story about ideas
got it I think am I wrong
I don't know I just despairing so much
stuff
so much Beauty in this world
and I just I wonder at what point does
Middle School lunch table
when you compare it
to amino acids you compare it to
you go scuba diving I have done I suck
what's the most beautiful place you've
gone scuba dive uh Gilly tea off the
coast of Bali okay
I remember scuba diving off menjungen
Island in Bali and amazing but the Red
Sea totally blew my mind
I can't tell you how little I care about
Milo yiannopoulos and how much I care
about scuba diving in the Red Sea I
don't know maybe I'm just wrong there's
something wrong it's just to get back to
it we all used to talk to each other
and then this thing started dividing us
you know he started seeing all these
messages oh your boy said this your boy
said that time to come collect your boy
he's like who talks like this
um the internet and then we stopped
seeing each other
in our feeds
and we said well oh this is Vijaya got a
under Jack Dorsey and Jack had gotten
some system whereby he took his hands
off it because he knew that the terrible
things had to be done I think
and he just had this idea well if I have
to intercede at Twitter then something
has gone wrong with the system and you
had this person who was just very happy
bringing Health to the
to the internet but it disconnected all
of us it was very clear that our
engagement just dropped and then if you
complained about it it was because you
actually sucked and nobody cared about
your tweets
you had no idea where you were and so
all of this kind of good feeling
evaporated in part because people didn't
know how to fight as a as a team and
this is just
I would love to get back to the
masculinity riff a little bit
I don't think men know how to fight as
groups
and it's a key part
about masculinity and it really makes me
upset to see all of these people in
individual masculine space all right
if you're ever faced me three attackers
two of whom have knives and one of whom
has a gun here's your best move it's
like like you know you don't know you've
never faced this is the best move to
have a group of five friends with you
well first of all
yes
and having people's back
and so there's a there's a this is
something that I've spent an awful lot
of time over the last couple of years
the definition of addiction
is that you can find fulfillment alone
is something that I heard a few weeks
ago okay
the atomization
of
everybody
the generalized risk aversion syndrome
that we are seeing something called
extended adolescence or slow life
strategy from Gene twangy uh talking
about young people are getting the
driver's license don't know it but like
it immediately from the title
uh people getting their driver's
licenses later they're uh partying less
they're drinking less they're leaving
home later they're getting occupations
starting jobs later
um could this have been contributed to
through covert yeah probably
um but it was catalyzed it was already a
trend that was happening
it's affecting men particularly
because
male friendship groups are
more fragile in some regards than
women's
in 1990 the number of men who said they
had zero close friends was around about
three percent
2020 that number was 15 that's insane
the most common answer to the question
how many friends could you call on in an
emergency is zero the most common it's
not the average but it's the most common
more people have zero friends to call
them than have any other number
the challenge of modern masculinity
relates to that addiction quote the
belief that you can find fulfillment
alone and you see this in the the sigma
male meme Sigma mail grind set you know
no no this so uh you have you know Alpha
Beta the sort of red pill the blue pill
the purple pill halfway between the two
I don't know okay so
the sigma male steps outside of the
existing dominance hierarchy he doesn't
try to lead he doesn't try to do
anything he is a Lone Ranger Lauren to
himself
over the top of a lot of this meta meme
which is being created is a guy called
Chris Bumstead who is a three-time
four-time classic physique Champion Mr
Olympia okay classic physique is they
have weight limits which means that they
have a much more arnold-esque it's all
about shape and sculpture massive but
not a mass monster Phil Heath was sat in
that seat not long ago mass monster uh I
sit down with Chris this guy who is the
face of the sigma male meme okay perhaps
the one of the driving forces behind
young male belief at the moment and I
asked him
how much of what you've done and
achieved in business in personal life
and in your sport could you have done on
your own
zero I could have done none of it
I couldn't have gotten through the
difficult times emotionally without my
fiance
I couldn't have built my personal brand
without my best friend in videographer
Calvin I couldn't have run my business
without Vaughn and my other business
partners that are here I couldn't have
done any of this stuff and this is the
guy that he's in the ice tub as there's
dubstep music over the top of him saying
you don't need anybody else and so on
and so forth
the belief that you can find fulfillment
alone
is a lie
it is a lie
that people who have been hurt and
scorned and rejected by the world
Retreat into
there is a safety blanket of cynicism
that people can use it's sour grapes at
an existential level
the belief that
the upside of never trying is never
having to feel the pain of failure
and the generalized risk aversion the
extended adolescence the slow life
strategy
permits that to seep ever more into
people's lives in a world where we have
hyper convenience why should I feel
discomfort
so what's going on with the modern
masculinity movement
it's fractured so there is the
manosphere which is the broad term that
describes people talking to men I've
never identified with it I'm not a part
of it inasmuch as I speak to men about
things that I struggled with and they
listen perhaps someone could put me in
it but I I don't think that they help I
think fundamentally at the moment the
masculinity movement sees women as
adversaries and competitors rather than
compatriots
I I think that they are they treat women
largely like an enemy to be avoided or a
resource to be used and discarded I
think that largely much of men's advice
benefits some men at the expense of most
others that if being a high value man
means sleeping with as many women as
possible but a low value woman is a
woman that slept with many men what you
are doing is creating a wake after you
that other men have to pick up the
pieces of if your goal is to be this
high value many but high body count male
I think that
let me give you this so This is actually
going into a paper my first academic
paper that I've ever been a part of all
right so this is the male sedation
hypothesis okay
there's a
an effect called young male syndrome
have you heard of this nope if you have
a large number of dispossessed sexless
men throughout all of history bad things
happen yeah testosterone drops when you
get in a relationship it drops again
once you have kids
this means in large part that women
domesticate men in some regard they have
to
you don't want to take risk-taking
behavior when you've got a newborn at
home don't jump off that cliff
okay like let's be go home go home so
when you have large numbers of
dispossessed young men who aren't having
sex
what's their reason for integrating into
society they take a brilliant study is
done of men crossing the road and the
difference between when they cross in
the distance from the nearest car
with or without the presence of women
you put a woman there the distance
closes massively no women there they're
not bothered risk-taking behavior is a
show look at my excess Fitness yeah look
at all of these risks that I can take
look at the plumage on the back of my of
my tail right so
throughout all of history it seems like
they set cars on fire and push over
granny and and cause havoc in Portugal
uh 1700s
they the first Sun there was a disparity
in the sex ratio I'm not sure why the
first son was allowed to marry every
subsequent son was put on a ship go
explore the new world
don't burn our home was what they were
saying
there is a question we have very high
rates of sexlessness and we have very
low rates of integration amongst young
men at the moment why are we not seeing
them going around and setting up setting
cars I'm fine there is a Jordan Peterson
was featured as the incel god in a he
inspired a movie by Olivia Wilde
starring Harry Styles a little while ago
I brought it up to Jordan
and uh
the incel God he was the king of the
incels yes this insult I am so
pissed to hear this
John laughed it off in classic him
fashion yeah but as a guy who who opened
for Jordan Peterson on harmonica I've
been to some of his shows
Jordan Peterson recognized this
demographic early
and he had the courage to speak directly
to it
and if you want to see some you want to
see me break out in tears have me tell
you the stories about the people who
went up to Jordan Peterson and said I
was smoking weed masturbating in my
parents basement and six months later
I've got a job I've got prospects I've
got a fiance
etc etc
and to turn him into the incel king or
whatever no Jordan Peterson tried to
become the one person answer to the
world Uncle shortage
okay and
I just have no patience for dismissing
that much good if if some of his message
seemed off to you it's because you
didn't need it you didn't understand
what clean your room was about you
laughed it off because you weren't
screwed
and he gave people a pass just the way
Sam gave people a path from that abusive
religious household where they didn't
know to escape
and you know to to an extent
all of these people spoke
to people at different stages in their
lives a lot of this female Behavior
which is oh you know I'm on only fans
I'm going to get my this I'm going to
get my that well good luck to you I hope
it works out
but the gold digging or the misogyny
it's of a peace people are listening to
each other's strategic conversation and
saying why would I want that for my life
so I'll round out the sedation
hypothesis
you have this large cohort dispossessed
young men high tea high risk taking they
cause problems there's a question to be
asked although many of the almost all
mass Shooters including the ones that
hit all of the headlines were sexless
young men
given that we have the highest rates of
sexlessness amongst young men that we've
seen in a very long time there is a
question why have we not seen an in-kind
increase in anti-social Behavior
it's my belief that young men
specifically are being sedated out of
their status seeking and risk-taking and
reproductive Behavior through a
combination of social media porn and
video games I was waiting for it
so there is an idea from Diana sorry
social media porn and video games does
not include weed
I think ubiquitous weed
the motivation killer
um
we don't have a ton of culture around
open weed we have a lot of culture
around open alcohol about open coffee we
used to have culture around open
nicotine
we don't have a lot of
culture around open weed we have culture
around closed weed surreptitious weed
yeah yeah but I do think that in part
the video game thing is an absolute as
if drug
what's up
you meet people who come from The Gaming
Community or social media and they have
an idea that life permits you to do
certain things that are absolutely not
tolerated in Civil Society
like a lot of the people
an interesting feature of social media
is the difference between critics and
trolls who call you names
and people who actually try to find a
way to ruin your life offline
like there's a huge connection between
The Gaming Community and certain sort of
bulletin boards and this freak game
about how can we destroy people offline
yeah yeah so I
um
and once you meet these people and you
and you read their messages to each
other they're talking about oh yeah I've
got a cool exploit where I'm going to
invite somebody to so-and-so's house
because I think that person might be
dangerous you realize it's a video game
yeah so I I had this idea specifically
about uh Jordan but it would apply to
yourself it would apply to Joe
after a while there is a particular
threshold of exposure notoriety that
people cross and when they do they are
no longer treated like a human
it's easy online to dehumanize because
you don't see any there there right you
don't see that but there's something
specific about crossing a particular
threshold where you're no longer a
person you're a representation of ideas
you're a conglomeration of viewpoints
and I think that really allows people to
dehumanize the other side really read
there is no one reading these three well
you think Jordan Peterson's reading
these tweets about the incel God thing
yeah is he I don't know I I think he is
I think Jordan spends I would I would
love Jordan spend less time on Twitter
okay I think that would be I think that
that would be good but
even if they're not there is a person
there that is the representation of the
person and I don't know like saying
something to somebody online that you
wouldn't say to their face to me seems
like a cowards
way of communicating or you'd view it as
an Adaptive landscape which is new
exploits have been created I mean if I
explain to you a mosquito life cycle
okay you're gonna find somebody with
excess blood and you're gonna steal some
for yourself that's my video guy he's
been eaten alive since we've been in La
yeah is that right yeah okay but you see
the same cookie cutter sharks do the
same thing for large Marine Wildlife
they'll just take a plug of flesh out
it's like
can't afford to go after cookie cutter
sharks
when you have those kinds of strategies
am I going to sit around in the ocean
and say no that's not a legitimate
strategy you're a parasite it's like
yeah
like that's my whole game where I'm a
predator I just murder things for a
living
it's really what predation is about and
in a certain sense what you've done is
you've changed the Adaptive landscape
and these are the new exploits
yes so the to get back to the video
games porn and social media uh Diana
Fleischmann has this idea she calls
uncanny vulvas and tell me what she says
that uh porn has been able to hijack the
mate seeking Behavior specifically of
men by giving them a very titrated dose
of what it is that they uh would usually
get which means that
part of that motivation to go out and do
the risk-taking behavior has been tuned
down but what do you get from uh video
games you get camaraderie you get
progressive overload in terms of your
achievements you get a sense of
belonging you get a dopamine when you
achieve something you may even get some
serotonin because you feel like you're
lumped together with your group of
friends okay and then what you get on
social media with social media we've
gamified the status hierarchy it's there
there's a number right in front of you
and there are levels that you can get to
there's your silver plaque on YouTube
there's your gold plaque there's your
blue tick look who followed me today
Elon Musk followed me today whatever
whatever I got a retweet from Paul
Graham
um
it has been able to and I don't
necessarily think that this was by
design it could be by by side effect it
has been able to specifically for men
maybe also for women
give a titrated dose
of
most of the key drivers that got people
out of the house to go and do things
Scott Galloway trended uh earlier on for
saying
that unless you're asleep as a young
person you shouldn't be in the house and
his point is life is for living there is
lots for you to learn outside
off go out come on uh and he got
tons and tons of pushback and
maybe he's wrong
but when I get advice sometimes on Q and
A's people will say young guys and girls
will message and say I'm 13 and I love
your podcast like what the
fantastic you are in a growth period
that is unbelievable and the people that
you're getting exposed to I wish that
I'd been I'd had access to at 13. what
should I do if I want to improve myself
what books should I read what practices
should I do
I don't mean to be patronizing but just
go outside and live life there is so
much low-hanging fruit from knowing what
it's like to have an argument with your
friend and having to cycle home with a
flat tire it just things there is so
many life experiences that I think you
will gain massive amounts
huge huge amounts of benefit from over
and above
a 2d lesson so me and my friend George
have this conception of a 2d lessons and
3D lessons so a 2d lesson would be
reading about Warren Buffett's wealth uh
through an autobiography or watching it
a 3D lesson would be hanging out with
Warren Buffett at his house for an
afternoon
and no matter how immersive we try and
make learning 3D lessons are always
going to win because you can't you can't
forget them they're so visceral and in a
world where most of our time an
increasing proportion of our time is
spent online
the in-person 3D lessons become more and
more and more powerful so this is my
conception of the male sedation
hypothesis hmm
how do you
how do you judge our sperm counts and
testosterone over time
yeah so there's some evidence Andrew
human shared some evidence that although
sperm counts are decreasing penis length
is increasing which
but that's I don't know
if I recall correctly and I I hesitate
to get in get into your penis literature
Eric come on well
there is some trade-off in in various
reproductive systems between things that
we would classically associate with with
masculinity so for example dung beetles
have uh Weaponry on their head called
antlers giant hook
and their copulatory apparatus and their
antler is in inverse proportion it's a
derailleur and chimp thing again right
that one of them has lots of testicles
and very little penis length and the
other one has the reverse
so you have a lot of these conserved
systems where somehow reproduction says
you can have this many total resources
but you have to figure out how to budget
between various things that appear to be
strongly masculine so
I think that declining testosterone is a
a big concern uh I would say that it
certainly contributes to uh a
generalized change in male Behavior
risk-taking you know it is talk about oh
and
um women that take birth control can
impact the local Ecology of male
testosterone by basically making it feel
like they're around infertile women when
they're not they're just artificially
suppressed women that impacts a man's
testosterone level men that are around
weapons if mean you walked past a table
of guns yeah the testosterone would go
up if we walk back there's a chainsaw
over there so perhaps it's already high
I'm not sure and
do I see how many volleys we can get
yeah do football freestyle
um
the
issues of sperm count the issue of
testosterone production I think
contributes to this in a large way what
it is that's causing this is it
phthalates in the water is it women
peeing out their birth control and we've
got estrogens in the water supply
is it the foods that we're eating is it
seed oils is it the lack of time outside
is it grounding is it you know there are
a whole host of things that are
contributing to this but I started
working with the blood testing company
uh Maric Health about six months ago and
I had my Bloodstone for the first time
the testosterone was about 500 uh and
I'm 35 and I was like you know it should
be higher than that so what should I do
they gave me some lifestyle
interventions and some Boron that frees
up free tea from sex hormone binding
globulin and blah blah blah blah blah no
pharmaceutical interventions but they
gave me a ton of Lifestyle ones I had my
Bloodstone a couple of weeks ago and it
was 900.
over the last
six months
there's been a
some minor but noticeable changes to my
demeanor one of them being I'm more
aggressive
like my frustrations come to the fore
love it and so
I mean I'm dying to ask are you first of
all are you married no in a relationship
in a relationship
do you find that women
heterosexual women respond to classical
masculinity
I have to be very carefully as I ask
because they certainly respond more than
they're supposed to according to Modern
rules of femininity correct but my guess
is that it's greatly decreased
from
the market for masculinity in the 60s
let's say so look
again
Inta and intra-sexual Dynamics something
I've spent an awful lot of time learning
about I'm writing a book at the moment
with David Buss evolutionary
psychologist okay on this
in the early 2010s after the success of
50 Shades of Gray
there was a proliferation of dark
romance novels and they
there was a pushback from the feminism
movement saying that the portrayals of
men as dominant masculine bearded
big-chested in a line cloth or a plaid
shirt wielding an ax uh wasn't what
women wanted they wanted a softer more
like the brawny guy or the Marlboro Man
correct they wanted a softer version of
this so they started putting more
agreeable more feminized men on the
front cover of books
they didn't sell right but I wouldn't
guess that either of those would be
where modern women's heads would be at
now
in the space of tanyas so I think that
there's a there's massively a difference
between stated and revealed preferences
sure right and also to you know to
caveat that the thing that you may
sexually fantasize about is not
necessarily what you want to get into a
relationship with
guys will say say more not that uh what
you optimize for on a one-night stand
and what you optimize for in a marriage
partner aren't always necessarily the
same I would think they would be wildly
desperate correct which means that the
front cover of the romance novel is not
necessarily the partner that you want
long term they're the one that you want
to fantasize about
most of these stories are driven by sex
rather than driven by love
so I have this hypothesis and I wonder
if you you have names for all sorts of
things that I let before you give me I
just need to Bunch this up your acronym
your panchon for acronym acronyms yeah
and a friend Mary says meme first
explain later and I think that uh some
of my favorite episodes they rely on
aphorisms they rely on on creating memes
sure small quippy razors and so on and
so forth first off because it makes it
easy to remember but secondly because
that's what gets the hooks into you this
is how you make things so if you are
somebody that's listening that has an
idea that really loves that idea give it
a name give it a name and give it a cool
name yeah I came up with Fame seesaw the
other day which is that uh on your way
up people want to support you because
you remind them of their dreams when
you're at the top they tear you down
because you remind them of what they
gave up on yeah yeah same seesaw
beautiful and that even if it's
wrong you can't forget it so it's good
very nice you were saying
um
that when women when heterosexual women
realize that they have several possible
life cycles and they don't have a clear
sense of which one they will actually
live
am I going to get married and raise
children and be at home with the
children am I going to get married and
have one child maybe two and be a career
person am I never going to couple but
have children am I going to have no
children whatsoever am I going to do
that in a coupled situation yeah
their decision trees blow out as to what
it is that they're actually looking for
and one of my strong senses
is that women
encountered something they weren't
expecting which is that they might even
be smarter than the guy at work who
they're competing with
but he's happy to come in
all of Saturday all of Sunday and work
hours that are completely psychotic
and so then the idea of well we need
work-life balance we don't want people
coming in on Friday and Saturday because
that's sort of an unfair advantage that
somebody who wants a healthy life is
different from somebody who wants an
extreme life
and so now you have this problem which
is I'm attracted to the sort of man I
wouldn't want to compete with at work
if I'm going to be in the office
I want to know that I'm not going to
have to deal with the guy who's willing
to give up every weekend and work hours
that I'm unwilling to work because
that's not how I'm set at the factory
versus
um
I want that guy
as the go-getter while I'm pregnant and
incapacitated and raising children to
make sure that not only he can Shepherd
our family through anything because he's
highly capable but can also get me back
into the workforce
when I'm done raising children
and
this is somewhat what I believe is
responsible for this sort of
incoherent messages that men and women
are sending to each other is that when
we don't know what life cycle we are
going to be inhabiting our eroticism and
our romance and our desire is unstable
one of the most uncomfortable
correlations that I've found over the
last few years is that
as gender inequality pay inequality
between the genders increases
relationship satisfaction for both men
and women increases as well
sorry decreases the more egalitarian the
more equal the pay the less satisfied
both sexes are with relationships hmm
men who are in relationships where the
woman is the primary Breadwinner of 50
more likely to use erectile dysfunction
medication
where a woman is contributing more than
70 of the household income the marriage
is twice as likely to end in divorce
women for a man sorry for a
woman to move herself the same distance
on a 10-point scale in terms of
attractiveness that a man can by
increasing his income by a hundred
thousand dollars she would need a ten
thousand times increase in income
in short
women are interested socioeconomically
in the status of their partner in a way
that men aren't now the problem that you
have is that women now have access to
education and employment in a way that
they never have done before so they're
no longer financially dependent on men
sure but you're seeing something which
is particularly heartbreaking in my
group of of females which would be women
in their mid to late 50s
I have to be honest I've seen
some of the women I was most impressed
by never coupling
and when I when you talk to them there's
some very uncomfortable things that get
said one of which was I was looking for
a man I could look up to and the pool
was just so small
and then and you know you're thinking
well okay it's illegal to say I'm
looking for a man that I could look up
to
right because that's not in accordance
with modern feminism and egalitarianism
but on the other hand this idea that
when you're
you know one of the world's leading
chemists or something uh there's just
not that many men that are gonna be in
that position I got another main fee
yeah this is I got in a lot of trouble
for this it's called the toll goal
problem so if you stand atop your own
status hierarchy it's very difficult to
find somebody else across an above from
yours you know if you're a six foot one
girl without heels you're looking at
professional athletes and two women for
every one man completing a four-year us
college degree by 2030 between the ages
of 21 and 29 women earn 111 pounds more
on average than their male counterparts
right but women still have this
vestigial attraction to the man who is a
cross and a bug from them that's
hypergamy and this means that as you
rise up through your undominance
hierarchy it amounts to a opportunity of
diminishing returns but then why are we
not allowed to build better men
I mean this is the really this is this
thing that just floors me
I'm now through through being a father
looking at
the subset of young men who are
absolutely looking to crush it
and the advice they're being given is so
horrific but like
well that doesn't seem mentally healthy
and uh
you know I think it's much better for
you to sort of enjoy this time with
everyone else and you know it's just
like watering down raw ambition
and
you know is it ludicrous who said get
out the way
you know
get out of the way of these people
these people want
to invest and blow your socks off and
just do amazing things and there's some
administrator or nanny or nurse ratchet
who's like well that would be arrogant
we can't have that and you're saying I
don't think you understand it but
ambition
is a necessary input for certain humans
and if you sit there and say why do you
have a right to innovate when nobody
else is innovated or uh don't you
realize that your go-getter personality
during the covid situation was based on
your privilege and uh in fact a lot of
other people are suffering from mental
health he's just thinking why am I
taking the most promising people and
tying them to the most damaged people
why not instead take the most promising
people and have them get a PhD by the
age of 2021 and study what to do for
their for their fellow Souls who are
struggling
do you remember when Elon took over
Twitter and he started to rip out the
tech team yeah and he said I want to
make Twitter a place where the people
who want to work the hardest on the
biggest problems can come and work and
people said they looked at that and said
this is going back to an archaic form of
Silicon Valley where people are forced
to sleep under desks and it's a blah
blah blah
those people
do not have theory of mind to understand
what it's like to be someone is driven
as it takes to look at that from Elon
not as modern day slavery
it can be modern day slavery or it could
be the person saying for God's sakes I'm
burning to solve this problem let me
sleep under my desk unhook
unhook the leash and let me go at this
and there is a there is a cohort of
people out there for whom that's their
calling they didn't want to work at
Twitter if they got
Frappuccinos and mindful Monday
afternoons off and to be able to play
ping pong for half the week and do
whatever it was that was going on
they want to go and they want to feel
like they're contributing to an
astronomically sized goal an
unreasonable goal and they want to feel
the the rush of of going toward it
and I think you're right I think that
there is a dampening of ambition and
since being in America since moving to
America 18 months ago
it's the fuel that I've had from the
enthusiasm from the people I've been
around has fueled me and powered me in a
way that I I didn't I wasn't it was
alien 33 years old and I'd never felt it
before
I wanna look
there's so much to do and it requires
ambitious people and those people have
to be both arrogant and humble it's a
complicated thing it involves mentorship
it's
I want to say also something about
elitism
elitism is incredibly unfair
you know I I've hung out with Stanley
Jordan and I am never going to play any
instrument the way Stanley Jordan plays
the guitar
he's an elite object I am not going to
be that guy you have to learn how to let
Elite people do Elite things that where
you can't compete with them
I don't know what to do about this
the idea that we're turning against the
concept of elite because we've got this
sort of pretend Elite that sits in these
chairs that screws everything up
and you've got all of these ambitious
people who are being destroyed by
enforced helplessness
you know how do we get how do we fire
the administrators necessary to return
universities to being universities
how do we
explain that some people are built to
fly wingsuits
you know it's a super dangerous activity
but somebody needs that Russia they're
not alive
you know people need danger they need
risk they need to be able to create and
they don't need you in their in their
way all the time
I I guess I just I have this very strong
sense
that
school has become the most dangerous
place that that we're pushing so many
people through school and school is
basically
it's destroying vitality
by the time you get through this
education that is so Laden with
administrators and people telling you
things that are wrong
like I don't know how to say this but
when when a friend of mine gets a call
as a chaired professor in a technical
discipline from a Dean who says we have
a little bit of a problem with some of
your current tweets what did I say so
it's not what you said but it's that you
liked somebody else's tweets and you're
thinking I don't care who you are
you'd never talk to a professor like
that
you you cannot have these people we need
the University of Chicago to spread its
middle finger
across the country and get rid of these
people
you can't talk to them
that they're a plague from Hell on
thought
you can't tax all thought by making it
nice
and and you know
something I I really don't know how to
communicate but I saw you got Sam Harris
in a certain amount of trouble so maybe
I'll buy a little bit of trouble for
myself
you can't have terrible ideas
circulating everywhere
leading to pogroms and riots and
killings and I was just in Istanbul one
of maybe my favorite city on earth
and I was reminded of the Turkish
Crystal knock that happened in the baolu
karakoi area of Istanbul where there was
a rumor about the desecration I think of
the birthplace of Ataturk and people
died as a result you know and and ethnic
minorities could not be protected you
cannot allow free speech to circulate
every dumb idea
infinitely until people are killed in in
pilgrims or Holocaust or whatever so you
do
you've got two options
you either constrain speech by rules or
by culture and this is the reason that I
was so against Milo yiannopoulos
you want a culture in which everyone is
allowed to burn the flag and it doesn't
even occur to you that that's something
you would want to do
that's culture you've got to load the
the inhibiting factor
on culture
and people say well that's what
cancellation is about it's like well but
if you misuse the concept of shunning
let's call it by something older than
cancellation
if you shun people for good questions if
you shun people for speaking truthfully
indecently as if they had done something
horrible then you lose the ability to
control bad behavior through social
norms and one of the things that I've
now come to understand is
we are either going to restore a culture
which shuns only when shunning is really
the correct course of action or we are
going to have rules that prohibit what
you can and cannot say and I am absolute
in that we should not have rules we've
got to put this on culture and we've got
to get a culture in which in general you
are very careful about the negative
things that you say
and one of the things that Milo did that
I really disliked was he said well the
purpose of free speech is to protect
outrageous speech and the answer is not
really
yes I if I'm forced to stand up for your
right to say horrible things I can do
that if the culture generally retards
horrible things but if the culture now
starts to encourage it
we can't have terrible ideas being the
precursor
of communal violence let's say and
we really shouldn't be having rules
determine what we can and can't say it
should be that when somebody starts to
say something
that is the beginning of an incitement
to Madness
that the cultural prohibition against
that is very strong
in my recent travels I've been shocked
I've been in Bombay I've been in
Istanbul I've been in Lisbon
Porto
in the islands of the Azores
none of these cities has fallen as far
as San Francisco
and Bombay is madness
but it's not we don't have a
homelessness problem in San Francisco we
have a zombie apocalypse problem we have
a dysfunctional government problem
when you can't say we cannot have this
in Union Square we just can't we cannot
have a zombie apocalypse in Union Square
when that becomes controversial in and
of itself you've lost the plot and
partially what's happened is that we've
given up on high trust societies where
we more or less share each other's
values
that's the concept of the loyal
opposition
we both know what the goal is you have
an idea of how to get there I have a
different idea I agree that we're going
to have a contest and one of us will win
and one of us will be grudgingly go
along with the other person's idea
when when your idea about what a just
Society is well let's vindictively
punish successful people let's pretend
that male and female have no difference
or all the difference According to some
set of rules on Alternate Tuesdays let's
decide that
um we can redefine what a recession is
or the Consumer Price Index let's decide
that we don't need masses yes we do no
we don't yes we do because of the
science science
can somebody get rid of these people
we need to be in a society that makes
some semblance of sense
and
we cannot go in these opposite
directions as far as I'm concerned when
you say we don't want no more police
you and I cannot be the loyal opposition
to each other
you're not you're not the kind of a
person I even understand
somehow that idea got into your head and
it made sense to you
and it's now carrying the day
I have always supported some amount of
reasonable gun control
I changed on a dime with that abolished
the police we don't want no more police
to fund the police
are you telling me that people are not
going to be allowed to own a weapon and
you're going to get rid of the thing
that was supposed to centralize the
violence on behalf of the state and make
it follow rules
there's no coming back from that and I
think that one of the things that we
just have to learn is that many of the
voices that we've been listening to
because they got jobs in our organs
whether it was the New Yorker or the
Washington Post or a professorship at
Duke
we have to stop listening to these
people wholesale we have to stop being
tolerant of the intolerant
if you come from a position that is
sufficiently Extreme and your whole
point is to try to use and weaponize
democracy to weaponize free speech to
weaponize good faith to weaponize what
it means to hold a debate
you need to not really have a voice at
the table because we don't have a
solution
if you say that I am entitled to sit at
this table as a member of the suicide
bombing Community strapped with a vest
filled with high explosives
the presence of C4 in your vest
invalidates you being at that table
that's trying to come up with a solution
if you say fundamentally I don't believe
that we should be having children
because humans are evil and we need to
bring this all to a to a close it's very
important that you not be on the city
council
because that city is a thing that is a
generational endowment
when you hand it to the next Generation
eventually you don't live there anymore
we are somehow seating people who are so
nihilistic and so freakishly
divorced from anything that we should be
able to assume as a default
like certain positions that probably had
10 adherents appear to have millions of
adherents and if we don't get rid of
these self-extinguishing theories we are
going to self-extinguish so I I believe
that Civil Society has an obligation
stop listening to positions that are
avowidly self-extinguishing
Eric Weinstein ladies and gentlemen Eric
I really appreciate you what's next what
can people expect from you have you got
anything interesting coming up
um more than anything
remember that the whole point is when
you see a person with a shirt that says
there is no Planet B
look at the night sky and remember that
the only way to get to planet B is to
change what we understand about physics
and so look for me on that front
thank you cheers mate thanks be well
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode with Eric you will
love this one with Jordan Peterson go on
press it